>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Dr. Carla Hayden: Good
afternoon and thank you
for coming and welcome to
the Library of Congress.
I'm Carla Hayden.
The 14th Library of
Congress and we're looking --
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
And we're looking
forward to a very,
very exciting afternoon
celebrating the 50th anniversary
of the signing by
President Lyndon Johnson
of the Public Broadcasting
Act of 1967.
And we have four star
studded panel s in store
for you featuring
many great names
of public broadcasting
both in radio,
on radio and in television.
And I want to take this
opportunity to single out one
of our guests here today.
His name is Mr. Henry
Morgenthau, III.
And he said I could
tell you this.
He is 100 years old.
[ Applause ]
And he was working
at WGBH 50 years ago
when the act was passed and
his grandfather was Henry
Morgenthau, Jr. who was
FDR's treasury secretary.
And I am proud to
say that the Library
of Congress has the
papers of his grandfather.
And so sir, we are truly honored
that you are here with us today.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Many of you may know
that the Library
of Congress is the largest and
most comprehensive collection
of motion pictures, television
programs, radio broadcast
and sound recordings
in the world is honored
to host this event with WGBH,
Educational Foundation
our collaborators
in the American Archive of
Public Broadcasting or AAPB.
The Library received its first
public television programs in -
and at the Library of Congress
I get my centuries mixed up.
1964 from the precursor to PBS,
the National Educational
Television and Radio Center
and incidentally just last
month we digitized two
of these programs so that they
could be more accessible via the
Library's website.
Now the Library's public
broadcasting holdings have grown
exponentially since 1964 to
include tens of thousands
of film, video and
audio masters from NET,
PBS, NPR, WNET and WETA.
And in addition to the thousands
of access copies we routinely
acquire as copyright deposits
from public broadcasting
stations
and producers across the nation.
And as the chief steward of
Americas and the World's Record
of Knowledge we took
to heart the television
and video preservation study
commissioned 20 years ago
by the Library of Congress,
which characterized
public television
as "the richest audio visual
source of cultural history
in the United States".
And so we are proud to
join with WGBH to ensure
that public television's legacy
survives for future generations.
Now at this time I'd
like to make some news
and that's why I'm
kind of excited.
I want to announce some
exciting new acquisitions
and projects related to public
broadcasting preservation.
First of all, and as a Library
you don't get to break news
that often, so you news
people bear with me.
I want to thank Mr.
Dick Cavett for donating
to the Library his collection,
ooh I heard a little
something going on.
[ Applause ]
>> Mr. Dick Cavett for
donating to the Library
of Congress his collection
of approximately 2,500 shows
from 1968 to 1996, including
the 1,000 shows he made for PBS.
He interviewed more than
5,000 guests for these shows.
And the list is astonishing,
and a testament to his ability
to draw people not normally
seen on late night television,
Katherine Hepburn,
Alfred Hitchcock,
Angela Davis, Marlon Brando.
And on one of the more memorable
and notorious shows Gore
Vidal and Norman Mailer.
[ Applause ]
And he also featured rock and
roll musicians to a degree,
pretty unusual for the
time including John Lennon
and Yoko Ono, Jimi Hendrix,
Janis Joplin, David Bowie,
Judy Collins and Joni Mitchell.
So, I was pretty excited to
announce also that today,
the AAPB will launch an amazing
new exhibit on its website
that will make public
television's first coverage
of the senate Watergate
hearings available -
I'm breaking news all over.
Television's full coverage
of the senate Watergate
hearings available online
for the very first time.
This was one of the -
[ Applause ]
This was one of the
most popular series
in public broadcasting history.
And the Library of
Congress has digitized all
of the master videotapes of the
coverage we received from WETA
in 1989 and with their
permission are making them
accessible online to
anyone in the United States.
The broadcast created what Dick
Cavett has called Watergate
junkies, to refer to
himself and others
who watched the hearings
obsessively.
The exhibit was created
this summer by a Library
of Congress junior fellow,
Amanda Ricobec, a history major
from Yale who is with us today.
Could you please
stand up Amanda?
[ Applause ]
We sent the detailed background
essay she wrote to Jim Lehrer,
who anchored the coverage
with Robert MacNeil.
Jim also is here today.
And after reading the
essay he wrote back "It is
as terrific as it is accurate".
And two years after
hearings MacNeil
and Lehrer worked together again
on another landmark public
broadcasting program.
I think you've all heard
of it and the rest of it is
as they say is history.
Jim has commented
that without Watergate
"there would have been no
anything called MacNeil Lehrer".
Jim will be on a panel later
today and will show a few clips
from the Watergate coverage.
AABP also is in the process
of making available online
full interviews conducted
for a number of landmark
PBS series.
Ken Burns' the Civil
War, Eyes on the Prize
and the definitive series on
the Civil Rights Movement,
Eyes on the Prize and the
American Masters Biography
Series and American Experience.
So, they are telling me to get
off the stage because there is
so much more I could tell
you about the project,
but I've run out of time.
So I want to think Ms. Patricia
Harrison, President and CEO
of the Corporation for Public
Broadcasting for their support
of the Library of Congress.
Unfortunately we're learning
that Pat's flight has been
delayed and she won't be able
to join us this afternoon
but could you please give
her a hand in absenteeism?
[ Applause ]
And I'd like to introduce
Letitia King,
Senior Vice President of
Communications for CPB
to speak on her behalf.
[ Applause ]
>> Letitia King: Thank you
Dr. Hayden and thank you
for your leadership and also for
hosting this important gathering
at the Library of Congress.
I would like to recognize
Senator Markey and thank him
for his important support,
not only for his home
town station WGVH but also
for his leadership
advocating for and helping
to sustain a vital public
media system for all Americans.
[ Applause ]
It is largely because of his
and others consistent support
of public media that we are
here today celebrating the 50th
anniversary of the
Public Broadcasting Act.
The 1967 Act articulates
a vision
of a strong public media
service providing access
to every American to the
highest quality of educational
and informational content
for free and commercial free.
The goal then as is now, to
strengthen our civil society
through content that
would result
in educated informed
and engaged citizens.
The three pillars of
a vibrant democracy.
From 1967 to 2017 the Act
continues to provide us
with an evergreen
mission and vision
for public medias important
role in American life.
And one that the Corporation
for Public Broadcasting,
CPB is proud to advance.
Because the Act created CPB and
designated us as the steward
of the Federal Appropriation,
tasking us with insuring
these funds went
to public media stations
to serve underserved
and unserved communities,
from our youngest
to our oldest citizens.
We are directed to utilize
technology and innovative ways
of connecting to new
generations to serve
as American's largest classroom
to help inspire life-long
learning and to invest
in journalism that is fact
based, in depth and committed
to editorial integrity.
Today PBS, NPR and nearly
1,500 local public television
and radio stations in rural,
small town and urban communities
across the country are
fulfilling the mission
and vision of the
Public Broadcasting Act.
Reaching 99% of an increasingly
diverse America with content
that continues to be a value
long after the initial broadcast
or digital presentation.
Content that has cultural and
historical relevance provides us
with insights about
the way that we were
and about the way we
are now as a people,
as a civil society,
as a democracy.
The value of this
content is priceless.
But it was deteriorating and
would no longer be accessible
to future generations.
That is why following a two
year pilot that began in 2009,
CPB provided almost $3
million in grants in 2011
to public media stations
so they could inventory
and protect their
station archives.
That first step helped
to build the foundation
for the American archive
of Public Broadcasting.
But CPB did not do this along
and we are appreciative of WGBH,
the Library of Congress
and many others
for their ongoing commitment
to this important initiative.
So in addition to thanking Dr.
Hayden and Senator Markey I want
to thank Jon Abbott
the President and CEO
of WGBH for his leadership.
WGBH is an innovative community
focused station providing public
broadcasting for New England
and is also PBS's leading
content provider, producer
and a major supplier of
programming for public radio
and digital content nationwide.
Jon's leadership has resulted
in a strong partnership
with the Library of Congress
to preserve public
media's legacy content
through the American Archive
of Public Broadcasting.
And we are so appreciative
of his commitment.
Please welcome Jon Abbott.
[ Applause ]
>> Jon Abbott: What a gathering.
What an honor to be with so many
of these extraordinary leaders
through the history of
public broadcasting.
Thank you Tish.
Let me add my welcome to all
of you who have joined us today
for this extraordinary
meeting, this opportunity
to share these panels and these
reflections, this history.
And my special thanks to
Dr. Hayden for hosting us.
The Library of Congress
is a fitting location
to mark this milestone
for public media.
As many of you know WGBH and
the Library came together
as Tish mentioned four years
ago to form the American Archive
of Public Broadcasting
to collect the significant
historical content created
by public television and radio
stations over these 50 years.
Because of the vision and
support of Pat Harrison,
CPB and its board the American
Archive is preserving the
programs that witness
our collective history
and tell America's stories.
More than 100 public
television and radio stations
across the country from Maine
to Guam have shared their
content with the archive.
The collection now has over
50,000 hours of content
and we are adding
25,000 hours every year.
And in keeping with the mission
of public media the American
Archive is available directly
to the public with some
23,000 programs in addition
to resources available daily
for educators and researchers.
WGBH is proud to be working in
partnership with the Library
of Congress to preserve
these historic treasures
and to make them available
for future generations.
And I'd like to acknowledge our
dedicated American Archive team
Sue Canterwicz, Karen Cariani
and Casey Davis-Sucoughlin.
[ Applause ]
And on this anniversary as
we celebrate the legislation
that created public
broadcasting,
we note with gratitude the
federal government's investment
in our work, consistent,
persistent and forward looking.
For SGBH one individual in
particular of course embodies
that support and that is
our senator Edward Markey.
Now he had very much
hoped to be with us today
and we're sorry he
couldn't join us.
He has served on the advisory
council for the American Archive
and has served on the hill for
40 of the public broadcasting,
of public broadcasting's
50 years.
He knows our work very well
and throughout he has been
a star work champion of all
that we aspire to do
for the American people
across the country.
Our thanks to all of you for
being with us here today.
I'm very much looking
forward to hearing
from our extraordinary group
of panelists assembled
for this occasion.
So, I'll turn this back to
our host Dr. Carla Hayden
who may squeeze in a few more
releases of new information.
It seemed like she -
she only got half-way
through her list I think,
which is very exciting.
Dr. Carla Hayden to begin our
proceedings and thank you again
to the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Karen Cariani: Unfortunately
everybody Carla had
to leave, so it's me.
You just get me.
I'm Karen Cariani,
Senior Director
of the WGBH Media Archive
and the WGBH Project Director
for the American Archive
of Public Broadcasting.
Alan Gevinson, my
esteemed colleague is
in the back managing our
audio/visual materials.
He is the special assistant
to the Chief of the Library
of Audio/Visual Conservation
Center,
a Culpeper for the Library of
Congress and Project Director
for the American Archive
for the Library of Congress.
So, welcome everybody.
Thank you so much for
being here celebrating our
50th anniversary.
Our first panel is about the
origins of public broadcasting
and we're going to start it off
with a clip from Newton Minow,
because in many ways we
wouldn't be having this event
if it wasn't for Newton Minow.
He serves on our
executive advisory council
for the American
Archive and this was -
he kind of planted the seed
for this event in our minds.
So, here we are and we're going
to roll a clip with
Newton Minow.
He was the FCC Chairman
during 1961 to 1963
and very instrumental in
getting the Public Broadcasting
Act launched.
>> Mr. Chairman hasn't something
happened this week speaking
about the government
and television
that has really revolutionized
the passing of this bill
for educational television?
>> Yes, the President
this week signed a bill,
which for the first time
will commit to federal funds
for the construction of
if you'll pardon the term,
educational television stations.
And to link these
stations together.
This will be the first time
that it's on a matching basis
with states and private
institutions.
The federal funds, public
funds will be committed
with this purpose.
I think it's a landmark.
You know in many
countries the government
operates broadcasting.
We've taken a different course
in this country of ours.
We said that broadcasting
should be in private hands,
and the commercial side
for private profit.
But in the public interest and
now we're hoping to develop
and build an alternative service
for those people who want it.
>> Newton Minow: Wish I
could be with you in person
to welcome you to this
important anniversary.
But in my 90's it's tough
to travel so I'm going
to communicate a little
history to you this way.
What I want to do really
is to tell you a couple
of stories about history.
My involvement really
stems 61 years ago.
In 1956 during the
presidential campaign,
my roommate in the campaign
travels was Robert Kennedy
who had been sent by the
Kennedy family to learn
about national campaigns.
They were looking
forward I think
to Jack Kennedy becoming
a candidate one day.
And Bob and I were the same age,
so we were often
roommates on the travel.
We got to Springfield, Illinois
and Bob turned to me and he said
"You and I have heard the
same speech 5,000 times.
If we've got time to walk
over to Abraham Lincoln's
house so I could see it.
I've never been in Springfield
and then we'll get back
in time to catch the plane".
I said, "It's only six or
seven minutes, let's go".
So we went over and
saw Lincoln's house
and on the way back
Bob Kennedy said to me,
he said "You know you and I each
have young children, families".
He said, "When I grew
up", Bob said, he said,
"I thought there were three
great influences on a child.
The home, the school
and the church".
He said, "I realize now raising
my own children there's a
fourth, and its television".
He said, "My kids
are on television -
watching television, they're
fascinated by television.
Can't we do something
to improve it?
Make it more educational
and informative for kids"?
Well that started
a relationship.
Then four years later when his
brother was elected president
the day after the election I
got a call saying would I please
consider joining
the administration.
And I really said no,
because I couldn't afford it.
We had young children,
had no money.
But they pressed and they
knew how interested I was
in television and they
offered me the job at age 34
of being Chairman of the Federal
Communications Commission,
how could I resist that?
We moved to Washington.
The FCC had been in
a series of scandals.
The place was a mess.
And my job was to clean it up.
The first day I was on the job,
the first issue I faced was
senate wanted our testimony
on a pending bill
to use federal funds
to help what was then called
educational television.
My colleagues all
said, in other words
at that time there were
seven commissioners.
They all said "No we don't
take a position on that".
I said, "Wait a minute,
our job here is
to protect the public
interest, certainly this is
in the public interest".
So by a vote 6:1 with my
single descent we testified
to the senate.
I was the one who said
that we were very much
for this legislation.
And I brought today something
that long preceded the public
television act of 19 - later -
this is the first act.
You see President Kennedy; I'm
sort of hidden in the background
with the senators
and congressman.
This was passed and
the President signed it
on May 1, 1962.
President John F. Kennedy
signing the TV Educational Bill
Senate 205 on May 1, 1962.
The - I was privileged
to do that in person.
I realized I had come to the FCC
from Chicago where we had WTTW.
President Kennedy had
come to the White House
from Boston, that was WGBH.
Little did we know that there
was no public television station
in Washington DC, the
capital of the United States,
not in New York City,
the largest city
in the United States, not
in Los Angeles the largest
city on the West Coast.
There were very few stations.
So I felt the first thing we
had to do was get more stations
and the way we did that
was to pass two laws.
One was called the All
Channel Receiver Act
which made television
sets have a UHF tuner,
which enabled news
stations to come on air.
The other was to provide
some funding for communities
to build public television
station.
So, we launched what later
became what is now today the
Nationwide system.
We also helped public radio
which had preceded
television in any way we could.
I always think that without
a station in New York
and without a station in Los
Angeles, without a station
in Washington it
would be impossible
to build a national system.
So, I'm very proud of that.
President Kennedy
was very proud of it.
And later when I
left the government,
went home to Chicago,
I became involved
in our local station WTTW,
later became Chairman of it.
Public broadcasting
has grown and developed
because it was bipartisan.
I tell our board here at WTTW
that the most important asset
we have is that the word trust.
It doesn't show up in
a financial statement.
But everyone trusts us, everyone
trusts PBS, everyone trusts MPR
as being honest and fair.
And that's why it's so
important that now we archive
and preserve the great
things we've done.
We celebrate the
50th anniversary
of the Public Television Act.
[ Applause ]
>> Karen Cariani: So if the
first panelist could come
up to the stage,
that would be great.
In that first piece with Eleanor
Roosevelt was actually thank you
to Henry Morgenthau, it
was one of the programs
that he produced for WGBH.
[ Applause ]
Our first panel is about the
origins of public broadcasting
and our moderator
will be Cokie Roberts.
Cokie Roberts is a
political commentator -
>> Don't do all that.
>> Karen Cariani: Please, please
I have it all written out.
Well I'm dying to at least say
she was cited by American Women
in Radio and Television as
one of the 50 greatest women
in the history of broadcasting.
And in 2008 the Library
of Congress named
her a living legend,
which we totally agree with.
[ Applause ]
>> Cokie Roberts:
Well I am thrilled
to be moderating this
panel because this is one
of the rare times in my
life that I'm the kid.
I joined NPR 10 years after
the Public Broadcasting Act was
signed, so I've been
there 40 years.
And these gents preceded me as -
>> Pre-deceased you?
>> Cokie Roberts: No, no, no.
Not - I didn't say deceased.
They were there at
the beginning.
And so they each have a
wonderful story to tell.
Ervin Duggan who is
immediately to my left was
in the White House at the
time that the bill was passed.
And then has been very active
as both an FCC Commissioner
and as head of PBS.
Nick Johnson was at the FCC
and a troublemaker all the time
and did PBS programs
as well as columns.
But was very involved
with public broadcasting
after he left the FCC.
Bill Siemering was really
one of the founders of NPR
and was the creator of
all things considered.
And Bill is still at it
running developing radio.
He would be happy to
accept contributions.
And so I think we'll
just start Ervin with you
and tell us what it was like.
How did you get the bill passed?
>> Ervin Duggan: Well we had
Lyndon Johnson who was a master
of politics and there
is really a hidden story
about how this came about.
And I hope that someday
a historian will delve
into what we call the
legislative task force.
As much as the great society
legislation including the Public
Broadcasting Act was crafted
outside the White House
and even outside Washington.
The Carnegie Corporation
Commission
on Public Broadcasting
for example,
the corporation headed
in New York.
Johnson decreed and Bill Moyers
was I think the point man
on this.
That the great society
legislation should be crafted
by these legislative task
forces in the universities
and the foundations
all across the country.
This really accomplished two
things; it removed the process
of drafting policy from
the eyes of the press
and from the atmosphere
of partisan politics.
It hid the process somewhat -
>> Cokie Roberts: It was secret.
>> Ervin Duggan: I would
call a benign secrecy.
And I don't think the
history has ever been written,
but if you look at
the 15 members
of the Carnegie Commission
you see the man JC Kellum
who headed LBJ's
television stations in Texas.
You see a Texan Oveta Culp
Hobby, you see the President
of the United Auto Workers.
Why? Because Johnson wanted
a tremendous lobbying push
and if the chairman of the UAW
in Detroit was one of the people
who crafted the idea
for the Corporation
for Public Broadcasting.
That meant that the
immense lobbying power then
of the United Auto Workers
would be behind the bill
when it came to the hill.
So, all of this was a part
of LBJ's legislative genius
and as I said earlier I hope
someday a historian will delve
into these legislative task
forces because it seems
to me one of the most creative
and really praise worthy
despite the secrecy,
one of the most praise worthy
things in that history.
And it's all a part
of a larger story.
Were it not for the
dark cloud of Vietnam,
I think the LBJ presidency
would be remembered
as the new deal is remembered,
as a flowering of creativity
and positive legislation
on behalf of the well-being
of the American people.
I see it - I see the
great society chapter,
which really ended at about 1967
after the Congress changed
its composition in '66.
I see it as the concluding
chapter of the new deal.
Johnson told Bill Moyers on the
plane coming back from Dallas
that he wanted to
do all the things
that Franklin had
been unable to do.
And so there was this tremendous
election majority that brought
on the coattails into the
congress a tremendous working
majority and he used that
majority to pass Medicare,
more than 60 education bills
including the great corporation
for public broadcasting bill.
The other thing and Newton Minow
mentioned it was bipartisanship.
The commission was made up
of Republicans and Democrats.
The support on Capitol Hill came
from Republicans and Democrats.
To this day if you look at
the trustees of the stations
around the country, when
I was traveling for PBS,
speak to trustees and
fund raising dinners
around the country
for the stations.
It was city arts and
business leadership
of every metropolitan
area in the country made
up largely of Republicans.
And what they could
be counted upon
when these periodic
outbursts of insanity occur
of misguided people wanting
to wound, they can't kill,
but wanting to wound
public broadcasting.
These Republican trustees
from all over the country get
on the phone and say
"What are you doing"?
>> Cokie Roberts:
They're still doing it.
>> Erven Duggan: They are.
And we can count on that.
John, Senator Warner then of
the previous Senator Warner
from Virginia told me once
that the Congress would never
kill public broadcasting
because it now is the
only way that a member
of Congress can get
on television
in his local community.
And so I hope that they
are inviting their members
of Congress to appear
frequently.
But I went to the White House
after the great landslide
of '64.
A really sort of gopher for
Douglas Cader who was in charge
of shepherding the corporation
for public broadcasting
into realty.
And our office in the basement
of the west wing really
became a sort of workshop
where the members
of the Carnegie Commission
first John Gardener
and then Ellen Pfeifer
around the conference
table in the office.
I would like to claim
some creative role in this
but I really was - I came
to the White House having
been a green reporter
for the Washington Post;
so I was a kind of gopher.
But I was also a watcher.
And what I watched was visionary
people doing amazing things
and it had a shaping influence.
It was a great graduate
school of my life.
And my boss hated
to write speeches
and because I had been a
newspaper reporter he would
shove all the speech
writing off to me.
And when we passed the
legislation and Johnson had
to make a speech, signing the
bill, I was given the task
of writing the speech.
And about 48 hours before the
speech was locked up and sent
into what was called the
presidents night reading,
John Gardner by now the
Secretary of HEW called
and he said "We need
to extend the vision
of this speech beyond
broadcasting and talk
about all public media".
And he didn't even know
what that meant at the time,
but he suggested language and I
want to quote a little bit of it
and then I will stop talking.
Because it is so prestian and so
visionary and so symbolic of all
that was going on in that
fertile period of our time.
Right in the middle
of the speech,
signing the bill
Johnson said these words,
"I want to create a great
network for knowledge.
Not just a broadcast system but
one that employs every means
of sending and storing
information.
Think of the lives
that this could change.
The student in a small
college could tap the resources
of a great university.
The country doctor
could get help
from a distant laboratory
or teaching hospital.
A scholar in Atlanta
might draw instantly
on a library in New York.
Now all this is 30 years
before the internet.
But suddenly the chrysalis
is beginning to form.
And the creative vision of
a network for knowledge.
The stations of NPR and PBS
have not always been receptive,
I'm sorry to say
to new technology.
They are more on the
broadcast technology
and a station manager once
said to me when we were trying
to create PBS.org, "Every hour
that a viewer spends looking
at a computer screen is an hour
that he is not watching
my station".
And so there's been
a certain hostility.
But we know that right
there in the womb,
when the bill was
signed the President
of the United States was
envisioning something called
networks for knowledge.
May that increase, may it
grow, may the commitment
of all public broadcasters
to public media flourish
in the future.
But it was great fun to be
in on the beginning though
I can't claim anything other
than a gopher's role.
But what a great thing we did.
It is now embedded
in the culture.
It is a part of American life
in the way that Medicare,
other great achievements
at that time are sewn
into the fabric of
American life.
And heroes of that
movement are in this room,
may their tribe increase.
[ Applause ]
>> Cokie Roberts: So
Nick, what was the role
of the FCC in all of this?
>> Nick Johnson: Well I would
like to go back a
little further.
>> Cokie Roberts: Okay.
>> Nick Johnson: Since
I believe Mr. Morgenthau
and I are amongst the more - age
of experience you know and so -
>> Cokie Roberts: The wise men.
>> Nick Johnson: Well not
necessarily as we often see,
but to go back to
the 18th century.
Because there are other
presidents involved
in this besides Lyndon Johnson.
With regard to whom I might add
an anecdote that he brought me
in February of '64 and
shortly thereafter a memo went
out to all presidential
appointees,
you may recall this
saying "I want you
to tell me what you think
would be in the best interest
of our nation with the area for
which you have responsibility".
And in my case at
that time it was ports
and ship building and shipping.
He made me Maritime
Administrator,
just exactly what
you would think a boy
from Iowa would -
the coasts of Iowa.
The coasts of Iowa and - should
the experience be limited
to operating a canoe on the Iowa
River but not very successfully.
Something that thankfully the
commerce committee found fully
adequate to justify
the appointment.
But I think that's another thing
to say about Lyndon Johnson.
That compared with
other presidents perhaps
who will go unnamed, that there
would actually be that focus
on what's in the best
national interest.
But I want to go
back to Madison,
who I just learned today is
referred to by those who work
at the Library of
Congress as Jimmy Madison.
>> Cokie Roberts: He was
Jimmy, spelled J-E-M-M-Y.
>> Nick Johnson: Is that
right, was it James Madison?
>> Cokie Roberts: Jemmy.
>> Nick Johnson: I'll be darned.
What, did your father
tell you that?
>> Cokie Roberts:
No I write history -
>> Nick Johnson: He was a
great - they would be so proud
of you now and everything
you've done.
No, I'm serious.
Hale and Lindy Boggs,
great people.
Well anyhow I wanted to
go back to Jemmy Madison,
however you spell his name.
And there is an inscription
as you came
into this building
you may have noticed.
And I'm going to link this
up with Thomas Jefferson
and then ultimately with public
broadcasting and try to do it
in five minutes or less
if that's all right.
>> Cokie Roberts: All right.
>> Nick Johnson: Yeah,
let's less would be better.
Less is more.
Yeah. And it contains
this line "People who mean
to be their own governor's must
arm themselves with the power
which knowledge gives".
That's Madison's quote.
Jefferson and many
of you may know this,
but when writing his own
epitaph chose to be remembered
as the father of the University
of Virginia and made no mention
of the fact that he'd been
President of the United States.
Now this is very
significant I think
because what these folks
were doing was recognizing
and establishing
and making efforts
to maintain fundamental
pillars of democracy.
Many of which have
always been and continue
to be today under attack.
One obviously is
extending the franchise
from originally white
male land owners over 21
to where now we even
let women vote.
>> Cokie Roberts: Took a while.
>> Nick Johnson: It
did take a long while.
And 18 year olds,
but then the addition
of free public education,
a fundamental element
and pillar of democracy.
And then the idea of
independent media protected
by the First Amendment.
For Jefferson also said
famously as you all know
and writing Edward
Carrington, "Were it left to me
to decide whether we should have
a government without newspapers
or newspapers without a
government I should not hesitate
a moment to prefer the latter".
And then went on in the
next sentence to say,
"But I should mean that every
person should receive those
papers and be capable
of reading them".
Again, tying it to education,
subsequently we added the idea
of free public libraries where
every American could have access
to the resources of kings.
And indeed, this library was
contributed to by Jefferson
in 1815 as you probably know.
Something that is often not
thought about in this context
but relates to what
John Gardener -
incidentally he wrote two
wonderful books - he wrote a lot
of stuff but that our paperback
books, one called Excellence,
one called Self-Renewal,
which I think are always worth
re-reading at least
every 20 or 30 years.
Because the other thing we did
was to establish reduced rates
for sending newspapers
and books and magazines
through the postal system.
Subsidizing what was at that
time the communications network
of the 19th century
was the post office.
And then we added telegraph
and telephone and so on.
But that was how it began and as
all of you know the early time
of radio and I want to tell
just one story about Iowa City
and then I'm done, is that okay?
Yeah, all right.
The early days of radio
involved numerous,
72 in the very early days,
educational institutions
that did not only the
technological work
of creating this box in
which little people lived
and could talk, but also the
programming and the focus
on the use of this as an
instrument of education.
Iowa City, Iowa from whence
I come, a city designated
by the United Nations as
one of three global cities
of literature, was created the
first educational radio station
west of the Mississippi.
That was in 1911, all right?
So this goes back before 1967,
for those who are younger
among us here today.
In 1971 WSUI became
a charter member
of NPR, one of the early few.
And one of the 90 stations to
carry the inaugural broadcast
of Bills, All things considered.
In 1916 it began transmitting
educational content,
ultimately including my
father's lectures in the 1940's.
By the last 1920's,
remember this,
1920's they had educational
television broadcasting
television images of
classroom content.
A station that would
ultimately be one
of the founding stations
creating Iowa Public Television
and thus end the
reading for today.
[ Applause ]
>> Cokie Roberts: Well Bill,
that nicely gets us to you.
The fact is that we heard
all about educational TV
and even though radio came
before it was something
of an afterthought in terms
of public broadcasting.
And you are the person
who changed that.
>> Bill Siemering: It
was actually Scotch taped
at the last minute
onto the legislation.
>> Cokie Roberts: And radio.
It's like the Civil Rights
Law putting "and sex" in
and changing women's
lives forever.
But so -
>> Nick Johnson: If I can note,
I took the position at that time
that we ought to forget about
television and start with radio.
You've got literally 10
times more for your dollar
with radio than with television.
>> Cokie Roberts:
That's still true.
>> Nick Johnson:
Really, that's right.
Build a really strong national
political base in support
of public radio that would
then clammer and demand
of Congress Public Television.
But to start with Public
Television and under fund it,
I didn't think was the
right political move, Bill.
[ Applause ]
>> Bill Siemering:
Because you're all,
or many of you are
historians and we've -
the history of the university
is I'd like to just go back.
A couple weeks ago I
was out in Madison,
Wisconsin celebrating
the 100th anniversary
of the oldest station in the -
the oldest educational
station, continuous -
>> Nick Johnson: But
east of the Mississippi.
>> Bill Siemering: That's right.
We can arm wrestle
about this one.
And tracing this back
to the university
because I think it
raises a good point.
About 11 years before radio
was invented the university
president of [Inaudible]
at Wisconsin said,
"I want the beneficence
of the university to be
in every home in the state".
And it became the motto of
the so called Wisconsin idea.
The boundaries of the campus
are the boundaries of the state.
And so that was the idea of
extending those resources.
And at that time the
very first broadcast east
of the Mississippi
and educational station
was information to farmers,
weather information, 60%
were - 61% literacy rate
at that time in Wisconsin.
And as just a side
bar Cokie mentioned
that I have an organization
developing radio partners
and we're working in Zambia
to improve the weather
and farming information where
the literacy rate is 61%.
So, radio continues
to be used this way.
So anyway, that idea continued
and so the beginnings
really were there
and I started my career in
public radio as an engineer
in 1952 working my way through
the University of Wisconsin.
So, that's where I - my roots
are there and there was a center
for innovation and
audio invitation,
innovation and so on.
They're producing radio
plays by David Mamet
and Arthur Colpert and so on.
Anyway, it was that
experience that informed me.
I left there and was in Buffalo
and developed a store front
center broadcast facility
in the heart of the
black community
where 27 hours a week
came from that source.
So I was, at that time giving
voice or helping give voice
to folks that had no - there
were no people of color really
in media at that time.
And we had discussions
about race on air,
what is it like to be an
African American in our society.
I had done some -
>> Cokie Roberts: What
year are we in now?
>> Bill Siemering:
We're in 1964 and 1964.
And I did a series on
the Iroquois Confederacy,
some portraits of that - of that
culture, Nation within a Nation.
Anyway, so when I was tasked as
a member of the founding board
to write the mission statement I
felt very strongly about radio,
that our first meeting
with a corporation
for public broadcasting.
I was on the radio
advisory committee.
And John Macy said to us,
"Well you know, of course,
television has to go first".
Of course, television
always goes first.
And I was really always
frustrated by this of course,
because - so I started a program
in Buffalo called
"This is radio".
This is radio dammit,
pay attention.
Look what - listen
to what radio can do.
I'm still saying the same
thing in development.
Anyway, so the task was to try
to, for me, differentiate it
from the educational radio,
from commercial radio,
from PBS that was of
course up and running.
To capitalize on the strengths
of radio as a sound medium,
getting out of the
studio, telling stories.
And to be somewhat
aspirational but also practical.
So that was what
I was trying to do
when I wrote the
mission statement.
If you don't mind I'll just
read a few paragraphs of that.
National Public Radio
will serve the individual.
It will promote personal growth.
It will regard individual
differences with respect
and joy, rather than
division and hate.
It will celebrate the human
experiences infinitely varied
rather than vacuous [Inaudible].
It will encourage
a sense of active,
constructive participation
rather
than apathetic helplessness.
The total service
should be trustworthy,
enhanced intellectual
development.
Expand knowledge, deepen
oral aesthetic enjoyment,
increase the pleasure of living
in a pluralistic society.
And result in a service
to listeners,
which makes them more
responsive informed human beings
and intelligent responsible
citizens
of their communities
and the world.
And then in the first
description of what became
of all things considered I said
that it would not substitute
superficial blindness
for genuine diversity of
regions, values and cultural
and ethnic minorities, which
comprise American society.
It would speak with many
voices and many dialects.
The editorial attitude would
be that of inquiry, curiosity,
concern for the quality
of life, critical,
problem solving and life loving.
The listener should come
to rely upon it as a source
of information of consequence.
That having listened
has made a difference
in their attitude toward their
environment and themselves.
And then the concluding
paragraph for now,
philosophically time is measured
by the intensity of experience,
waiting for a bus and walking
through an art gallery may
occupy the same duration of time
but not the same
time experience.
Listeners should feel
that the time spent
with NPR was among their most
rewarding in media contact.
National Public Radio will not
regard its audience as a market
or in terms of its
disposable income,
but as curious complex
individuals who are looking
for some understanding, meaning
and joy in the human experience.
[ Applause ]
>> Cokie Roberts: Well
so now you have a good
sense of how it all began.
And since these gentlemen
have been broadcasters we're
finishing right on time at 3:00,
in time for the next panel.
Thank you gentlemen
very, very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Henry Becton: Good
afternoon everyone,
I'm Henry Becton the chairman of
the executive advisory council
for the American Archive
of Public Broadcasting.
And when I arrived at WGBH Henry
Morgenthau was in his heyday
as an executive producer and
so he was one of my mentors.
And one thing that Carla Hayden
didn't have time to tell you is
that he still has
the urge to create.
He's just published
a book of his poetry,
his first book of poetry.
I've got a copy of it there
and what she didn't tell you is
that this is actually a
stop on his book tour today.
It is my great pleasure to
introduce this next panel
and its moderator,
Judy Woodruff.
One of our very special
colleagues in public media.
[ Applause ]
Judy began her distinguished
career
at the CBS affiliate in Atlanta.
And went on to be White
House correspondent for NBC.
Was the host of Frontline
in its early days,
host of inside politics for CNN,
guest correspondent for NPR,
author of several books and
co-founder and chairperson
of the International
Women's Media Foundation.
And along the way
has been honored
by many distinguished
organizations.
So, thank you Judy for
helping us today and we promise
to get you out of here
and back ready to prep
for the news hour tonight.
All yours.
>> Judy Woodruff: Henry
Bectin, thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Judy Woodruff: Henry
Bectin of course being one
of the pillars of public
media for so many years,
Boston and the whole country
has so much to thank you for.
Thank you Henry.
So I'm the lucky one now,
because I get to preside
over this panel of five
mega stars in public media,
the Pantheon of News
and Public Affairs.
Each one of them has played
an absolutely essential role
in keeping public media,
public television and radio
at the center of American life.
None of them needs
an introduction
so I'm going to be very brief.
Starting with my mentor, the
man you just saw in that clip,
the former anchor and executive
editor of the News Hour
with Jim Lehrer and
before that the co-anchor
and executive editor of the
MacNeil Lehrer News Hour,
the MacNeil Lehrer Report from
1975 until 2011, the face of
and the singular driving force
behind daily journalism at PBS.
All of this following
a distinguished career
in newspapers, Jim Lehrer.
[ Applause ]
>> He still needs a
haircut obviously.
>> Judy Woodruff:
Next my boss today.
I don't feel any
pressure at all up here.
The President and CEO of WETA,
Washington DC's flagship
public television
and radio stations since 1989.
Before that she served as a
member and chair of the board
of the corporation of public
broadcasting as well as a member
of the WETA board
following her service
on the West Virginia Educational
Broadcasting Authority,
Sharon Percy Rockefeller.
[ Applause ]
>> Judy Woodruff: The executive
director and co-founder
of Radio Bilingue Inc.,
the National Latino
Public Radio Network.
In 1976 he was the
moving force of a group
of Latino farmworkers,
artists, activists and teachers
who founded Radio Bilingue in
California San Joaquin Valley.
Hugo Morales.
[ Applause ]
Someone who is already
been applauded here,
the longtime host of the Dick
Cavett Show, over five decades.
His remarkable career in
television has spanned networks
from ABC, USA, HBO
and of course PBS.
He's appeared in
movies, TV specials
and several Broadway
plays, Dick Cavett.
[ Applause ]
And finally the aforementioned
living legend,
the woman who moderated
the last panel
with a mm-mm year background
along with me in broadcasting,
political commentator for
ABC News and of course
for NPR contributor to the
MacNeil Lehrer News Hour,
advisor to the American Archives
of Public Broadcasting,
Cokie Roberts.
[ Applause ]
So what we're charged with
doing is looking at how news
and public affairs
came into being
and how it evolved
in public media.
Jim, I'm going to
start with you,
you were there almost
at the beginning.
When you came to Washington
it was all about Watergate.
We saw that clip, what happened?
>> Jim Lehrer: Well
the Watergate -
the Watergate hearings
really did -
that was the water
shed event for news
and public affairs
on public television.
Up to that point the stations
and the public was
generally divided
over whether they even needed
any more news and public affairs
on television beyond
what was already there
on commercial television.
The Nixon Administration
particularly didn't think there
was a need for any more
news and public affairs
on public broadcasting.
But the Watergate -
the Watergate hearings
changed everything.
And the reason it changed was
because there are several
individuals who had the courage
to make some really
tough decisions.
And one of them was not to
necessarily broadcast them gavel
to gavel because many
of the stations would
not broadcast it live
because they had educational
TV on during the day time.
But somebody and I was part
of the mix of the somebody's,
said "Why the hell don't
we run them at night?
Repeat them at night"?
And that was a big, big deal.
It was a big decision.
And the people who were running
PBS were nervous about it
so they said, "Let's
poll the stations".
So but we - we did
poll the stations
but we polled the stations
in a very clever way.
We polled the stations with
a question that was kind
of phrased in such a way
"Do you want to be patriotic
or do you want to be a jerk" And
we still barely won a majority.
But as MacNeil said at the time
and I quote him almost verbatim,
well the option - because it was
summertime and PBS didn't have
that much to run at night anyway
- they had no original programs
to run at night anyhow.
So he said, "Well
all they would run
if they didn't run the hearings
would be" - how did he put it,
English speaking people
talking, animals mating,
and occasionally English
speaking people mating
and animals talking.
[ Laughter ]
So why not replace it with
the Watergate hearings?
That's why when I said 3:00
a.m., the hearings weren't going
on till 3:00 a.m., that
was the repeat every night.
We would do it live
all day but we only had
about maybe half the
stations were watching it,
were broadcasting it.
But at night the -
and it wouldn't -
it was the old story you know,
the big stations wouldn't
take it, but then they started
because the word got out
and then suddenly it
became a big deal.
And the big deal was that
it proved beyond a shadow
of a doubt that there was a
role for news and public affairs
on public broadcasting because
of those hearing and out
of that came the news
hour and everything else.
>> Judy Woodruff: So
when you and Robin cooked
up the MacNeil - it was
MacNeil - Robert MacNeil report
and quickly the McNeil
Lehrer Report and then -
>> Jim Lehrer: It began
as I said a million times,
it began with the worst title
in the history of television,
Robert MacNeil Report and I was
the Washington Correspondent
and then it became
-my mother interceded
and it became the
McNeil Lehrer Report.
It was one story a day for
30 minutes when we started
and then - that was '75.
And then in '83 it went to an
hour, became the news hour.
>> Judy Woodruff: And
that's where I want to bring
in Sharon Rockefeller because
Sharon you were already active
in public broadcasting
and you knew what Jim
and Robert were trying to do.
What were you up against when
they tried to go to an hour?
>> Sharon Rockefeller: The
stations in many senses.
I was working - I was familiar
with West Virginia Educational
Broadcasting Authority,
not on the board at that time
because my husband
wasn't governor.
And that was a gubernatorial
appointment.
At the time actually I asked
for one thing from my husband,
"Can I be appointed to the
WVEBA" and he said, "Yes".
And no one ever thought
twice about it,
but that was my training.
That's where I learned.
But the Watergate
hearings actually,
I watched every single
day, all day long.
Jay had lost an election by the
largest margin in the history
of the state in 1972, we
had four years in exile
in Buckhannon, West Virginia,
three hours north of Charleston,
three hours south of Pittsburgh.
But an hour and a half from
the Morgantown West Virginia
University Station.
So, when the Watergate
hearings were on in that,
I could not receive the
Washington Post by mail
until two days after
it was published.
I started watching full time.
My kids were watching
Sesame Street.
I loved history, Adam's
Chronical, Masterpiece, but news
and public affairs was
my main attraction.
It was what we had to offer.
We at that point was
little old public television
and it was the turnaround.
I also came on the WETA
board at the same time
through another vehicle,
a friend of mine
on the Stanford University
Board, which had one woman
on the board and I
was taking her place.
She was the founder of - this
is in the 70's, lest we forget.
She was the founder of
KQED, Caroline Charles,
so she said "Where do you live"?
I said, "West Virginia",
San Francisco, thank you.
She said, "Where's that"?
She said, "Is that
near the Dakotas"?
"Is it near the Carolinas".
But she knew Mrs. Campbell
and she called her
immediately and I was 29.
She said "You have to
talk to this young woman".
I didn't know what about.
But Mrs. Campbell called me
in a very authoritarian way,
"You must come to Washington
right now", which I did.
I've always taken my orders
from Elizabeth Campbell.
And that's how I got
involved with WETA.
So I had a very small
[Inaudible] and at
that point WETA was not
as wealthy as it is today.
It had a budget of 4 million;
now we're at 97 million.
But we've clawed our way up.
And it's really through
news and public affairs.
The Watergate hearings put
public television on the map
and WETA and the News Hour,
which came about in 1983
because we thought we
should be the first,
and that all stations were
going to go to one hour of news.
In fact, they never did, we did
but we won, if you recall Robin
and Jim and I went around to
visit stations, speak to them
and they didn't really want it.
We did not want it -
>> Jim Lehrer: We divided
up - we divided up the 300
and some public television
stations
and we called every station
manager or program manager
because Irv's successor
as president of PBS said
"It's a great idea
to go to an hour,
but I don't have
the power to do it.
You're going to have to
get the stations to -
get the stations to do it".
So we physically called
them on the phone,
and then there was a vote.
We won by six votes.
To go to an hour and
out of 300 and some
and that felt like,
oh never mind.
>> Sharon Rockefeller:
All you need is one more
than the other guy.
>> Jim Lehrer: Democracy won.
>> Judy Woodruff: And as
they say the rest is history.
So, Dick Cavett, while all this
was going on in the daily news,
daily journalism world, you
had a very successful career
as an interviewer in
commercial television.
What was the appeal
of public television?
>> Dick Cavett: Well I noticed
in something about today
that among the things
that I thought might come
up would be the question
of why I moved my show
from network television to PBS.
I was fired.
[ Laughter ]
I hope that's not too
loquacious a way to put it
but that's pretty
much what happened.
So opened the door, paved the
way, whatever clich you prefer.
It was a wonderful change
with network television.
I was of course delighted
to get a show.
Terrified and very
nervous at first.
And the trouble there,
the kind that would come
up on network so-called
non-public television
so to speak starting
on the first day.
I thought I had a
wonderful show,
Present them is my first show
to be played about a week later.
Mohammad Ali, Gore Vidal
and Angela Lansbury did a
wonderful talking lively show.
And foolish boy from Nebraska
that I am, I went backstage
to be congratulated by
ABC Vice President sort
of shepherded the show.
And I saw his expression
didn't seem appropriate
for a show that he loved.
I think it was worded "Who the",
let's say hell gives a damn,
that's a better word
"what Mohammad Ali
and Gore Vidal think
about Vietnam"?
Well obviously that had come up.
Second brilliant part
of his reaction was
"We can't really air that as
the first show because of that"
and "We're going to air
it as the second show".
And I seem to remember
saying "Are you going
to be like this all along".
And I saw agent Sam Kohn
wince over in the corner.
And they did.
They did that.
I did a second show that was
nice and we had them both
and they aired the
second show first.
And it got mildly
enthusiastic reaction.
And then they aired the
first show the second night
and reviewers were
reviewing the whole week,
so almost everybody said
about the second show,
"the Cavett show really found
itself on the second show".
[ Laughter ]
I was sure that - the man who
had been waiting backstage for -
to congratulate me, got a
copy of that [Inaudible].
So that sort of thing happened
and then there were other kinds
of troubles that I
would not have gotten
on and didn't on PBS.
One involved that
lovable old couple;
the John Lennon's
and they come on.
And that was an event and
other people were jealous
and the reviews were big
and the ratings were big.
And that was nice, and
they even came back.
John when I met him a week
earlier before the first one
said - I said, "Why do you
want to do this really?
There can't be much you
need at this point".
And he said, "You have the
only half-way intelligent show
on television".
And I said, "Why
would you want to be
on a half-way intelligent show"?
And he laughed as
many of you did
and we were friends
from that point on.
But, on the second show who'd
have guessed the agreement had
been that we would do
one of their songs.
And John said, "Why don't
we do one of Yoko's songs"?
It had the catchy title "Woman
is the Nigger of the World".
And I thought are they kidding.
By God, we did the song
and nothing happened.
But, before it was aired I was
told that it would not be aired,
the song, and I complained.
And they said, "Well all
right, we will air it,
but our decision is that
you will make a statement
beforehand" about the dangers
of watching it I guess.
I remember one of the -
and there were 412 perhaps
protests about the song.
None of them about the song
though, but as one woman put it,
about that mealy
mouthed speech you made -
delivered just before.
By delivery sort
of encouraged that?
So, getting to PBS was going
into a green meadow in a way.
>> Judy Woodruff: Well
I want to hear more
about the green meadow, but
Cokie I want to come to you
because we heard Bill Siemering
and I think Ervin Duggan
both say words to the effect
that they felt that NPR should
have had the early head start,
early boost that PBS did.
Did you feel that
when you first went -
>> Cokie Roberts: Oh sure.
It's still true to some degree.
But it turned out to be a
blessing I think in the end;
Bill could probably
talk about this more.
That it was kind of a secret
at first because at the point
when Nixon did go
after television
and basically the television
network committed suicide.
The NPR was still there.
And there was no
necessity to disband it
because it wasn't on the radar.
And so the ability to just grow
and thrive was much
easier in that environment.
But then the growing
and thriving became something
quite dramatic and as
of today we are listened
to by more people
than the three you know
morning editions listened
to by more people than the three
network morning shows combined.
It is listened to by more
people than anything other
than Rush Limbaugh and
I keep saying you know,
Steve Inskeep should get
what Rush gets, right?
But because of the
different in ratings is
about a half million people.
And so it is wildly successful
and really the primary source
of news for millions
and millions
of people around the world.
>> Judy Woodruff: And
commercial radio has pulled back
from that dramatically
over the years.
>> Cokie Roberts:
That's also true.
>> Judy Woodruff:
Leaving a big opening.
So you Hugo Morales, you
were paying attention
to all this in California.
But you and some of your
friends decided there was
something missing.
What did you see?
>> Hugo Morales: First
of all I was a little -
at that time little or no news
on radio and that is true today.
In Spanish language commercial
radio there is no news.
I mean that sounds - we still
have [Inaudible] those of us
who believe in the
mission, but it's absent.
I mean it's a shocking truth
that there is - there is no news
in Spanish radio
except for [Inaudible].
And when we got started back
in '76, let's take the -
we got started in 1976, but -
we got started on July 4, 1980.
But 1980 the population
of Latinos in the US was
around 15 million which is about
6.5 % of the US population.
Now it's 58 million and 185
of the population and 72%
of Latinos speak
Spanish at home.
So, this is not something
of the past, you know some
of us were young at
that time, right?
And that we had big dreams.
And - but rather something
that is very relevant today.
And yet there is no news
in Spanish language
commercial radio.
>> Judy Woodruff: Stunning.
>> Hugo Morales: It is
very, very stunning.
It's a story that some of us
don't want to perhaps believe
but it is true and so back in
1976 when we started organizing
or I started organizing
Bilingue in Fresno.
It's a community that I came to
because I was born in Oaxaca,
and raised in Sonoma County
where the fires were recently.
And then went to
the Silicon Valley
because it was the largest
concentration of farm workers
in the United States, which
is still it, is today.
You know it's - in the amount
of people that I came in contact
with they saw the same thing.
All these Chicanos,
Mexican Americans,
all of them were US
born except for me.
I was the only immigrant.
And all of us were
bilingual and educated.
We were the first
generation of Latinos
to be open the doors
to higher education.
So that contributed a lot to
why Radio Bilingue was founded
because we saw this
degree of limitation
of public broadcasting,
but not public -
just public broadcasting
but I mean you know,
English language media
that we as Latinos,
our families could not access
just because of the language
and so - but it's not
just the language.
The language and I see everybody
here you know there's much more
than the language, the
culture, the history
and the nuances of language.
There's a literature,
there's a poetry,
there's arts, there's all that.
And that was absent in terms of
- and we as young people thought
"Well wow, it seems
like our treasures,
our community treasures,
our hidden treasures",
we have so much you
know wealth of history.
We have so much wealth of art.
And so forth in our communities
and we should be able to share
that and learn from one another.
So that's why we
establish Radio Bilingue
in 1976 [Inaudible]
on the air in 1980.
>> Judy Woodruff:
And it's still going.
>> Hugo Morales: And
it's still going.
And we also believe of course,
that public affairs
[Inaudible] had to be part of it
because what we wanted to do
is just like in this situation,
we wanted to us, as Chicanos,
Mexican Americans and Latinos
to tell the story have our
own narrative to be inclusive.
I mean if you look
at for example the
prison population today
in the United States.
You know something
like 1% of the
in prison population
in the US is Latino.
So a lot of our communities in
need, the highest dropout rates
from high schools continue to
be Latinos in the United States.
And yet you see the figures
of how we are significant now
in number of - and we'll
project it to go even larger.
So, that's when we
find it rather bleak
because we wanted
that to happen.
So, we've been able to document
and follow some of the stories
that some of the
other media have not.
For example there's a case
of indigenous woman living
in the south who was denied
you know, parenting her child
at birth because she could
not communicate in English
or Spanish because she
spoke a native language
from my home state of Oaxaca.
So it's that kind of a case
where you some community
folks there
from I think it was
Alabama called our station
and told them the story.
We broke the story and the
news media picked it up
and eventually she recovered
her child but that's the kind
of stories that we covered.
Or, right now what's happening
is talk about the need,
there's a lot of fear
among our families
about you know deportations.
And maybe to those of us in this
room it's just another topic
but to people who listen to us
or listeners it's
very, very personal.
I mean just I think
about a month,
a couple months ago we had a
call from a mother, from Teresa,
California, where we opened the
lines and also given information
that at that time the
opportunity to renew [Inaudible]
and she was saying
that her son had gone
into depression after
the election.
He knew what was
about to happen.
And he was a [Inaudible]
recipient.
And he had quit his college
upon after the election.
And soon later he quit his job.
So the mother was very
worried about her son
and what was about to happen.
So that's the kind of stories
and narratives that
are [Inaudible].
>> Judy Woodruff:
You're touching stories
of all American lives and
that's what public broadcasting,
public media was founded to do.
Jim let's talk next for a
few minutes about how hard
or not it's been to survive
as public media as news
and public affairs
and public media.
A lot of competition
out there, the news,
the commercial news environment
has changed so drastically.
Why has public media remained,
news and public affairs remained
as strong as it has
do you think?
>> Jim Lehrer: Well first of
all we - MacNeil and I said
at the very beginning and
that if people started -
if commercial television came
along when cable started growing
in fact, particularly if they
started doing what we're doing
we quit doing it.
There's no point in our doing
what's available elsewhere.
We'll go on and do
something else.
And we had a lot of ideas about
the things that we could do,
but as we sit here now
nobody is doing it right.
And in fact there is more -
now more than ever they would
say the kind of journalism
that is practiced on the
news hour is more needed now
than ever before
because journalism
on television has had its
own growth and its own kinds
of changes and those changes
have been away from the kind
of separation of straight
reporting from analysis,
from opinion and that sort
of thing which is still true
of the news hour but not
true in some elements
of commercial television,
particularly cable television.
And so the reason for our
being, let's cut to the chase,
the reason for our
being is stronger now
than it has ever been.
>> Good point.
>> Judy Woodruff: I will
let that just sit there
because I think it's right.
[ Applause ]
Sharon, as somebody who
has to look at this both
as you know journalists very
well, but you have to think
about it as a manager,
as an executive.
How hard has it been to keep
news and public affairs going?
And we should add, I mean you
- you over see the Ken Burns,
it's not just the news
hour and Washington Week.
It's the Ken Burns
Show and many others.
>> Sharon Rockefeller:
I think what's one
of the things that's great
about the public
television audience is
that it's pretty well educated.
Above all, it continues
to want to learn.
So keeping up on a daily
basis is important,
but putting in context
weekly as we do
on Washington Week
is very important.
And history, the arts, science,
kids all of the rest means we
serve so many different people
in so many different ways
but our signature is the
news and public affairs.
It's the hardest to fund and
yet our membership money
essentially helps subsidize
although we raise d a
lot for the news hour.
We raised a good bit
for Washington week,
but we never make a profit,
let's put it that way.
We always reinvest
in the product
and could spend a lot
more than we take in.
I think it is our
trademark, our signature.
We're very proud of it and I
think our audience is proud
to be associated
with what we do.
>> Jim Lehrer: But it's
always been difficult
to keep it funded, always.
We never had - we don't even -
the word surplus doesn't even -
it's not even in our vocabulary.
We're always under - way over
- either over budget or having
to cut back and that's
been from day one.
And I hate to say this
but at the very beginning
when we first started which was
now 37-38 years ago there was a
commercial television guy
named Marvin Kalb I ran
into him socially.
We'd been on the air a
year or two at that point
and I didn't know Marvin Kalb.
And he said, "Well you
guys are doing things" -
he said "Let me give
you a warning"
and I said, "Yeah what's that"?
He said, "Don't let them
give you too much money".
And I said, "That's
not a problem.
But just for the hell
of it tell me why"?
And he told quick story
and he had scads of them.
But one in particular
nightly news, CBS news,
Czechoslovakia has been invaded.
He was going to do a minute,
a minute and a half thing on
and it's going to
be a major story.
They kept cutting it
back, cutting it back,
cutting it back, and
about a minute before air
or two minutes before air they
got some great fire footage
from downtown Little Rock.
Now nobody was hurt in the fire,
just great pictures of fires.
And they cut his report
back to 20 seconds.
And he said if they
hadn't had the money to buy
that fire footage I would
have had my minute and a half.
So it - and it was -
it stuck in my mind
because I just told
the story again.
And - but - and McNeil
always said that too.
If you get too fat and
sassy you'll - you will -
you'll do things that you would
do - you'll do things that you -
that are not required.
This way you're limited
by - money limits you
to do what you must rather
than what you just
kind of want to do.
>> Cokie Roberts: In radio
that's really not true
because what we're doing
is opening bureaus all
over the place.
And when we're living in
a world where what happens
in Syntagma Square in Athens
affects your 401k then you need
to have more international
coverage rather than less.
And of course more national
coverage understanding what's
going on in this country.
And so really the money goes
to those very expensive
foreign bureaus which are very,
very difficult to do but I would
argue essential in this time.
And so we need all the
money we can get, thank you.
>> Jim Lehrer: It's probably
a story I shouldn't have told.
>> Sherry Rockefeller: Judy
the one thing I would say is -
sorry to interrupt, that
corporations in the early days,
we went to AT&T, etc.,
etc. without huge amounts
of money in retrospect.
That has diminished drastically
but foundations have
really upped the ante.
And they understand, they're
more visionary, they have a lot
of money now and it's not
we've never had a surplus.
But foundations and individuals
who support the program.
We have, you know you
can give as an individual
to support the PBS news hour,
which was never possible before.
But we're doing that in
a membership kind of way.
>> Did the funding situation
effect the work you were able
to do, do you think
in any way, you?
>> Dick Cavett: I
recognized my name,
but it wasn't - see
I like fires.
What a story that is.
I was never thoughtful
or thinking
about such things as funding.
It's a bad habit sort
of frame of mind for me.
And I had to be urged every now
and then to make a phone call
or make an effort,
something like that.
But I was thinking of
shows that I was able to do
and people said,
"Oh you're going
under public television now,
that's for intellectuals".
I - intellectual is a very
dangerous label to have put
on you when you're in
television whether it's public
or the other sort.
But I remember appreciating
the fact
that ABC would have gotten a
little nervous when I would have
on England's great entertaining
performer, actor, philosopher,
teacher, John - the
great Jonathan Miller -
one of the greatest
intellectuals in captivity.
And would have him on five
nights in a row a couple
of times and people wanted more.
I can imagine trying to do
that elsewhere shall we say.
So, I really wasn't
conscious of funding in ways
that probably were harmful to me
because I'm sure I might have
been able to help with it
if I had pitched
in in certain ways.
>> Judy Woodruff: But
did you feel the freedom
to do pretty much
what you wanted
when you were working at PBS?
Interview the people you
wanted and do the kind
of programming you wanted to do?
>> Dick Cavett: I did ; yes.
I usually just did the kind
of program I wanted to do
and in the [Inaudible]
I got away with it.
I'm not aware of any
particular gripes
of the sort I was
used to on ABC.
>> Judy Woodruff: Well
good, we'll take that.
>> Dick Cavett: Am I
disgustingly happy?
>> Judy Woodruff: I'm
going to come back to Hugo
because I mean how do
you see this picture,
question of resources?
I mean how much of
an issue was it?
Are you able to ignore it?
I mean how does it affect
what you're able to do?
>> Hugo Morales: Well
first of all I want to say
that is really, really
important that we maintain
that independence of public
broadcasting whether it be
on radio or television.
That's a value that
we always have shared
in something we have
to be militant about.
And that is true also
for Radio Bilingue,
so how do you build
not just a station
but in this case a network?
We have [Inaudible] and
we have 60 affiliates.
How do you build a network?
What are you serving people
with literally no
disposable income, right?
I mean so it's - so part
of it is the employees
subsidize the service in part,
spend the history of public
television, public radio
at least at the beginning.
>> Judy Woodruff:
Subsidized how?
>> Hugo Morales: Well
with salaries for example.
For starters, and the
other is to be able -
to keep those employees,
you know that's a real,
real challenge for us.
But the other is that it's
foundations that have -
we manage to attract
but as the competition
for that has grown our
share of that has lower
for public affairs and for news
and for information
from the foundation.
That's competition
for this [Inaudible].
So it's really, really
difficult for us.
And so I would say that -
that for news and information
in Spanish [Inaudible] is
really, really difficult
for us to maintain that.
>> Judy Woodruff: So that leads
to my last question
for all of you.
How do you see the
future of news?
The future of public affairs
in radio and television?
Do you feel confident about it?
I mean I like to feel
very confident about it
because wherever I go I get -
I hear good things
about the news hour.
But what do you want,
what do you hear?
>> Cokie Roberts: I think
that one of the things
that we're learning is that
Congress actually likes NPR.
And they can't always say it
out loud, but the truth is
that it gets back to what
Nick was saying earlier,
they're all - they're on.
And it's in all of the districts
and it is the source of news.
But of course the federal
funding is a tiny percentage
of NPR money.
It's really just for the
satellite, but the stations rely
on it a lot particularly
the small rural stations.
And that's an important
thing to keep in mind
that these are people
who really are desperate
for this kind of information.
And sometimes it's also the
only emergency signal, you know?
All of that and so I think
that the fact of the service is
so widespread and diverse and
so well listened to by people
in all areas of American life
that I feel very
confident about the future.
But I do think it
requires resources.
>> Sherry Rockefeller:
I was going to say
that the last two
years, the last year
and a half have proven more
than ever indeed for what we do.
It is so complex, depressing
too many, hopeful to those
who thought they
were electing someone
who would stand for them.
But the country is
changing so fast.
The political system is
practically impossible
to understand.
We despair of being
ungovernable,
but who brings some sense
and order and rationale
to what happened today and
this week and this year,
plus analysis, plus thoughtful,
complex sensitive ideas
about what might
happen in the future.
We are doing that in a
way that nobody else is.
And if we just stay true to our
mission, stick to the straight
and narrow I think
we've got a great future
in news and public affairs.
>> I agree 100%.
[ Applause ]
>> Dick Cavett: I'm sorry,
two vaudevillians competing.
>> Jim Lehrer: I was
just going to say amen
and add a couple of lines.
The basic need for
the Free Press was set
up by the founders.
And the key to our democratic
society is an informed
electorate, an informed public.
The only device that the
founders created by the -
through the first
amendment was the free press.
That's the device for
people to get information
to cast informed votes and
all levels of government.
And we are - but we in
public broadcasting,
but we in journalism, we
who facilitate journalism,
we who practice it and
we who participate in it
at any level are part
of a democratic process
that is particularly critical
right now with this explosion
of information that's
coming out, with the Tsunami
of electronic this
and that gadget,
and all this kind of stuff.
This is a critical time and I
agree with what Sharon said,
we must not lose sight
of what our purpose is.
And it isn't about
making people laugh,
it isn't about people
making - make them cry.
It's about keeping them
informed enough to function
as informed people in this
country, informed citizens.
[ Applause ]
>> Judy Woodruff: Dick.
>> Dick Cavett: I
too agree with Sharon
on that particularly in this -
>> Jim Lehrer: You
don't agree with me?
>> Dick Cavett: I'll
get to you in a second.
As we are all living in this
sea - what's seeming time
of plague certainly there
has to be the service
that only a public broadcasting
can do so well and can continue
to be this great garden
of thrilling varied
wonderful things
that are not available
elsewhere on television.
They're still not
beholden and they are -
public television is
still vital to our lives.
It sounds corny but
I believe it.
[ Applause ]
>> Judy Woodruff: If you're
not optimistic you can't speak.
>> Hugo Morales: I am
optimistic and I agree
with this distinguished panel.
And in terms of Spanish
language news and information.
I think the need is there
for basic information along
with news and information
to the Latino community
and I think the future for
Spanish language mediais
to be able to communicate
that informed, so thank you
for the invitation or what the
reality is and the need for that
because it's so critical and
so thank you very, very much.
>> Judy Woodruff: So
critical, so critical.
I just want to - I want to
thank all the panelists.
But I also want to quickly read
a little bit of an an email.
We, at the News Hour
got yesterday
from our colleauge Jeff Brown
who had been interviewing
inmates at San Quentin Prison
for a story they're working
on about a pod cast
they're producing,
which is going ot
appear on the News Hour.
But what I want to share with
you is Jeff wrote all of us
to say that several
dozen inmates
in different partsof the
prison, different places
from different parts of
the country came up to him
and the crew while they
were there to say "Hey PBS,
we don't know what we
would do without PBS".
But they went on to say how much
the program means while Jeff is
interviewing an inmate in one
cell they can hear the program
in the next cell
being listened to.
So, I just want to say that we
are reaching - we reach people
in public media in every
corner of this country.
We're not just in the
intellectual capitals
and the political capitals and
the places of great wealth.
We are in parts of the country
where people are struggling
and trying to get their
lives back together.
And those are the stories
that we will always tell along
with all the others, so
what an amazing panel.
Thank you.
>> Jim Lehrer: If they were
- some of those inmates were
to join their local public
broadcasting it would be a
wonderful funding -
>> Cokie Roberts: I will
just tell you one quick story
because it's so funny
but it gets
to the excellent
point you just made.
At one point when Susan
Stanburg was the regular host
of all things considered and she
took a leave to write a book.
A farmer wrote to her and said
"My cows won't give milk".
[ Laughter ]
He was always going into
the milking barn and turning
on all things considered and
they heard Susan and gave milk.
And without Susan no milk.
So -
[ Applause ]
>> Karen Cariani:
Thank you everybody
and thank you to the panels.
We're going to take
a short break now.
However, we hope you
will stay to watch some
of the clips we've put together
to wrap up this previous panel
and launch the next panel, which
is documentary style and use
of archives, which
will begin at 4:00.
Thank you.
So welcome back our next
panel is called documentaries,
style and the use of archives.
And Pat Aufderheide
will moderate.
Pat is a univeristy professor
of communication studies
at the school of communicationat
American University
in Washington DC.
She founded the school cneter
for media and social impact.
Her books include reclaiming
fair use, how to balance back
in copyright with Peter Yazzie.
She coordinates the Fair
Use and Free Speech project
at the center with
Professor Peter Yazzie
of the Washington
College of Law.
Pat, take it away.
>> Pat Aufderheide: What
a great pleasure it is.
I feel like my entire
life is passing before me
as I look around the crowd.
But this - to be on a panel
with these people is
really extraordinary.
Each of the people
here has been able
to not nearly make
great documentary.
But create a future
for a different kind
of documentary then was ever
possible on any other kind
of television to be made.
And each of them has contributed
differently to - todoing that
and also in some cases
supporting each other,
which is really - doesn't
- I dno't want to know
if I'm giving away secrets here,
but that doesn't always
happen in public television.
Anyway, and I've had the
pleasure of working with some
of these people as well
because as Karen mentioned
over the last decade Peter
Yazzie and I have been working
with different organizations to
make fair use more available,
particularly in archival
ways to makers.
And public TV broadcasters
including some
of these people have really
been incredibly supportive
and early adopters in being able
to make better use of material,
third party material
to tell America's story
in so many different ways.
I want to start first
with Clayborne Carson.
So Clayborne Carson
is the founder,
director of the Martin
Luther King, Jr. research
and education institute.
He was the senior advisor for
Eyes on the Prize at a time
when no one thought
it could be made.
I would like to ask each of you
starting with Clayborne to talk
about what - what - what did you
have in mind for these series,
each of you have
this experience.
The series that ended up really
providing a template for how
to do things in the future
for filmmakers and had -
really hadn't been done.
>> Clayborne Carson:
Well to start out one
of the things that's so
interesting to listen
to the previous panel is
that you know just yesterday
I was lecturing at Stanford
to my students who
were born well
after all this had happened,
and I think that
they were telling me
about a period before
I came on the scene.
And so I suddenly felt
young, younger in the sense
that when I was - I got a
call from Henry Hampton.
And, who should be here I -
unfortunately passed
away way too early.
But he was the visionary
of Eyes on the Prize.
And I had just accepted
an invitation
from Coretta Scott King to edit
Martin Luther King's papers.
So, it wasn't like I
was looking for work.
I - I realized that this
was going to take decades
and it has taken decades to
edit and publish his papers.
But what he was - he talked
about his idea for a series.
And I think one of the
themes that I see running
through all the discussions
this afternoon is
about democratization
of information
and the interpretation
of history.
Of the way in which ifyou think
back to the days before PBS,
before NPR, before the
modern documentary style most
information about the past
came from a few sources.
If you saw a documentary
it was usually made by a -
well they didn't have large
scale documentaries made
by anything other than
large corporations.
A lot of them, things
like CBS Reports,
things like that were done
by the commercial networks.
And what he was proposing was
to do something very radical.
And that is to get away
from the notion of history
as a master narrative told
by a handful of people
and written in textbooks.
And everyone kind of took
that as authoritative.
One of the first things he
said is there's not going
to be any what we now
call talking heads
in Eyes on the Prize.
That our job was not to
come there and pontificate
and the four of us who were
the senior advisors were all
really young.
And I don't think we
would have welcomed
that role in the first place.
But what our job was to go
and find how history was made
during the 1960's, 50's and 60's
and to go to the sources
and find those people
and let them tell the story
of how they made history,
not to interpret it.
And that was a -
>> It was a breakthrough -
>> Clayborne Carson: It was a
breakthrough because even now
when you look at documentaries
you see that many of them kind
of go back to that notion
by having the authoritative
historian kind
of give this interpretation
that's going
to guide you through.
And - but there's
this other story
of these ordinary
people who make history.
And the real joy of
doing it was that for us
as historians we were in our own
work, you know my first book was
on the student on violent
coordinating committee
which was not about King.
It was kind of the
counter king story.
So, I welcome that kind
of an approach and I think
that has influenced
the documentaries
that have been made since
then, that many of them do take
up that maddle of
allowing ordinary people
to tell the story
of making history.
>> Pat Aufderheide: And from
what you're telling is we'll net
- so one characteristic of this
is ordinary people telling this
story and also in
an oral history way.
I mean there was so much rich
oral history that had not been -
that would have escaped
us forever that was done.
>> Clayborne Carson:
And now it's interesting
because I could go
into my classroom
as I did just this week
and use those interviews.
I rarely use Eyes on the
Prize in the classroom,
butI use the interviews that
we did for Eyes on the Prize.
And often that works so much
better in the sense of it will
like get it to the point
where it fits what I
want to talk about.
I want to talk about Coretta
Scott King for example.
There's this wonderful interview
we did, extended interview
with her that maybe we used
at most five minutes of it
over the Eyes on the Prize.
And I find that my
students are so drawn
to the just seeing her
talk about ordinary things,
you know what was it like
talking to the President
of the United States when
your husband is in jail
and you've never spoken
to him before and he calls
on the phone, and your
young son answers the phone
and starts babbling away.
And you have to kind
of get him off
and say the President is there.
That kind of story is going
to get through and stick
in the minds of students
far more
than simply me giving a
lecture about Martin Luther King
and going to jail and writing
the letter from Birmingham jail.
>> Pat Aufderheide: Something
else that I think was
so important about Eyes
on the Prize in terms
of standard setting was that
I think it was John Else
but probably strongly
supported by Henry
and others really arguing
that every single image had
to be exactly what
you claimed it was.
It couldn't be like something
that looks sort of like that,
which was very common.
>> Clayborne Carson: Yeah
there was no reconstruction.
We had to - and in fact that was
when - there's a story actually
that kind of illustrates that.
We were interviewing
Ralph Abernathy
about the march on Washington.
And he told this wonderful
story about coming back
after that day at the March.
I was there too and
[Inaudible] particular meeting
when he talked about coming back
after all the people
had departed.
And in the evening seeing
the rustling of the -
you know the papers and
all the leftover things
and then he says it was
just the most beautiful day
of my entire life.
And I remember David
Garrow kind of saying
that it couldn't have
happened that way.
Why? Because we know where
Ralph Abernathy was every moment
of that day and so we had
this debate about whether
to trust his recollection
as opposed
to our historical
reconstruction.
And we decided to use it.
We said - history
might not have happened
that way, maybe it should have.
>> Pat Aufderheide: Well let me
jump to David if you don't mind.
Who I - I remember when he
was the brash young Australian
who was here -
>> David Fanning:
South African -
>> Pat Aufderheide:
South African, sorry.
Sorry, you know us Americans,
what's the difference
with other countries.
>> David Fanning:
We draw the lines.
>> Pat Aufderheide: Brash
young South African here
to bring us a whole new -
new format that was
possibly too challenging
for public television.
>> David Fanning: You
know I'm a creature of -
I'm a baby of public television.
I walked into a public
television station in 1973
in Huntington Beach as a young
filmmaker from South Africa
by way of London and the BBC.
And I walked in and volunteered.
I got my hands on the tools,
that camera and that [Inaudible]
that were there and began
working with Peter McGee
at WJBH found me ther ein
1977 and brought me to Boston
to start a series called World,
which was an international
documentary series.
And the idea was to do a series
about the world as
others see it.
And it was this wonderful idea.
I came to WGBH to
find a place that was
as extraordinary institution
that was dedicated to ideas.
And I had never been around
anything quite like it.
It was also that each of
the people that were working
in the different genre's
from science to history
to even Julia Child who was in
the back corner of our offices,
were doing things because of
they cared about the ideas.
And it was extraordinary
privilege and it is to this day.
This amazing privilege that the
reason there's a front line is
because we were trusted with
enough resources for long enough
to work it out, to try to figure
out how to do the best work.
And the privilege of being
able to give that resource
and to say how you get to
spend it and justify it.
And if you can't make the
best film you could make
about this subject,
then don't make it.
And it was as simple as that.
It wasn't me, it was all the
talented people that I could go
out and feret out and
bring to public television.
I tried that out with
World, we did 60 films.
And along the way but there was
a moment when I sat in a meeting
at the corporation of public
broadcasting with a man
who must be remembered Louis
Freedman was then the head
of programming and
he walked into it
and he said he was inundated
with thousands of proposals,
and he just couldn't
sort through it all
and he made a decision
to do three big strands.
One was going to be drama and
it became America Playhouse.
The second was childrens
and it became Wonder Works
and the third was a news
and documentary idea.
And I walked in with World
looking for a little bit
of funding to do eight
shows for the next season
and he made me sit down at his
table with a sandwich and figure
out what the budget for a 36
week series would look like.
And we counted it up
to 3 million dollars
at the time in 1970 - 1981.
And we came up with that figure
and said we could probably do it
for that much money; and he
said "Great I'm going to put
out a request for proposals".
And he put out proposals
to various people including our
friends at WET or proposed it
and we proposed it
and we got the money.
And the guarantee was that
we would have the money
for three years.
If we could persuade
the stations
to match the money progressively
over the course of
the three years.
It was a visionary idea and you
left us the freedom to do that.
And we made our mistakes and
we you know, bumped our heads
and we did some good things
and we found some smart people
and slowly this idea grew.
It grew of simply that idea;
so to Lewis, to Peter McGee
who found me on the beach in
Huntington Beach and brought me
to Boston, you know are the
people I thank for Frontline.
That's what made it happen.
And it really has
been as simple as that
and as complicated as that.
And -
>> Pat Aufderheide:
Although Frontline has -
it developed almost a brand that
you really did put your stamp
on a kind of documentary
that became a style
of making documentaries.
>> David Fanning:
Well I don't know,
you see I think there
were lots and lots
of different styles
of films within them.
They were observational films,
they were repertorial films,
they were investigative
films, they were films
like you know Marian Marzynski's
wonderful six hours called
Shtetl and they were
extraordinarily different films
that came about.
And I always thought that
we needed to make a series
that young and older
producers, reporters
and filmmakers would look at
and say "I can learn from that".
And the people who come to me
and say "How do you
make these films?
I'd like to get into
documentaries".
I say just watch a lot of them
and try to deconstruct them
and look for the different ones
that suit you for who you are
and the kind of film you make.
Because ultimately these
are works of authorship.
And if you encourage authors
and then encourage them
because they do good work
by giving them another film
to make then you begin to buid
a body of work at the time.
And Frontline has intiially -
Judy was anchoring the series
after Jessica Savage
in the first season.
But there's a certain point
we felt like we would sort
of take the extra time and
we began to use Will Lyman
as a voice and we made
that strategic decision
that you would hear this
- there'd be something
in the quality of the
words or the qualitiy
of the story telling
would say ah ha that's
that different thing.
That's that show and so
there was a value to that.
There are people who
qustion that Will is kind
of old fashioned and the
patriarchy and all kinds
of reasons that black people
would say we should be using
other voices, and we do.
But ultimately you needed t have
some kind of connective tissue
at times that would
hold a string
through the sets of films.
>> Pat Aufderheide: So you're
arguing if you could have some
of these marking features
then you could have a lot more
freedom, artistic
freedom in other areas.
>> David Fanning:
Freedom without it,
but yet you'd still - there
would be something other
than an anthology series
and the most important thing
about it was it was going
to be a work of journalism.
It wasn't going to be
an anthology series made
by independent filmmakers
who would come to us
with films pretty much
made and we would do -
we would actually initiate
and we would subject them
to the rigors of an
editorial process,
which mean that the journalism
had to be transparent,
we needed to go right into
it at any point and be able
to understand the source
materials inside that film,
and that was at the heart of -
>> Pat Aufderheide: Margaret
Drain, American Experience.
>> Margaret Drain:
I also wanted to add
that there is another binding
agent in front line and I think
when I came to GBH I discovered
this because I had come from CBS
where I worked at CBS
Reports and then a couple
of iterations of magazine shows.
And CBS Reports closed and
shut down because TV Guide.
You remember TV Guide,
an artifact of the past,
ran a front page story -
I mean a cover story saying
the documentary is dead.
And this was in 1985 I think.
>> Pat Aufderheide: That's
when documentary was
still a bad word.
>> Margaret Drain:
It was a bad word.
So everybody went scurrying
and I got a great job offer
from WGBH again from Peter McGee
who really needs to be mentioned
as many times as
posisble because he sort
of set the standards at WGBH.
And they wanted - Peter and
Judy Clayton was the original
executive producer, wanted
to do a history series
but the binding agent
in the history series
was good story telling.
It had to have a beginning,
a middle and an end.
Narrative, narrative, narrative.
We even constructed the
documentaries and acts
which was something that most
documentarians had not been
doing, you know they - they had
on commercial television you had
a lot of documentaries that were
like NBC White Paper
and ABC - I forget what
that series was called.
And they were surveys.
They were mostly surveys
from the top down.
They weren't stories, they
weren't actual stories
where you had characters that
you could follow and I think
that was an element that
was emphsized at GBH
and in particular I
know American Experience
because as we were talking
before you want to hear
from as many people as possible
who are as close to the subject
as possible and then
construct it very carefully
to have a story arc.
What happened then,
what happened next,
what happened after that?
>> Pat Aufderheide: So
you're - let's point out then
that public television
is - the real innovator
of this character
driven story model
that now is standard
expectation for documentary.
>> Margaret Drain: Yeah I think
so because I mean I don't want
to take the credit for
it because it was -
I didn't invent the
narrative style.
But it was something that was
embraced wholeheartedly by WGBH
and they gave all of us the
resources to figure it out.
Because when you tell
-when you're in the process
of telling a story you need time
to figure out what the story is,
who the main characters are, who
the secondary characters are,
where the at break is,
what's going to happen next,
how to conclude it and
without being - you don't have
to tel lthe entire story you
know, because everybody used
to agonize about
what's left out.
Well if you did your job
properly no one would even
notice that you left
anything out.
They would just - our philosophy
was just go narrow and go deep,
go narrow and go deep
and get characters.
But I do want to comment on
something you said before
about getting first hand
witnesses, because I admired
that in Henry Hampton's
Shop and Eyes on the Prize
and I thought it was terrific.
We had a challenge
because our mandate was
to tell all American History you
know prior - we had to go back
into the 18th century and
even the 17th century.
And we were terrified.
We actually avoided anything
that was pre-archival
because we didn't know how to
deal with it at the beginning.
And you can't find witnesses
who are - we did a show -
one of our first shows was
on the 1906 earthquake,
San Francisco earthquake.
We barely got a couple of people
to make an appearance and we -
as soon as we found them we
shot them immediately, you know
and put them in the bank.
Because we didn't even
know we were going
to go ahead with this storoy.
But it was a real
stretch for us and we had
to challenge ourselves to go
back into the 19th century
and even back into revolutionary
period, so we relied
on since we're here talking
about the archives letters,
diaries, first hand accounts
that could then be employed
in many different
ways to recall maybe -
maybe it was the
Donner party, you know?
I mean there's no first hand
witnesses in the Donner party.
One of our most successful
films and what did we rely on?
We relied on diaries
and letters.
>> Pat Aufderheide: So
one of the things that is
so I think impressive about what
both of your series ended up -
and all of your work
in documentaries did was
I think create a sense
of trust among the stations.
For something that they
had dreaded and feared ever
since the days of NET which
was before there was a PBS.
And you know shows
like the redliningshow
that made Nixon decide he should
defund public broadcasting.
So you sort of created a
sense of quality, dignity,
realibility, turnkey and so on.
Something else that is actually
really interesting to me is
that public television and
building upon that has been able
to actually foster
a kind of -and
as you descrbied
it anthology show
for independent voices as well.
And impressively I have to
say thank you to David Fanning
for being so supportive
of anthology shows as well
as these executive
produced journalism series.
And Stephen Gong who
is here from the Center
for Asian American Media, one
of the minority consortiua
of public - CPB, is also a
veteran independent filmmaker
and somebody who supports
independent filmmakers
and has also been involved
in creating archives
that we can all draw on.
So, I'd love to hear you talk a
little bit about the filmmaking
that goes to fuel the
two big anthology series,
POV and Independent Lens
and just like let me say,
board member of ITVS, yes.
>> Stephen Gong:
Actually ifI could,
I'd like to make a reference
to the panels we heard earlier
because the seeds of the
minority consortia independent
and diverse filmmakers really
goes back to the same era
of the great society; so many
of these entities were
founded in the 70's.
And it came out of both
civil rights and in many
of our cases Hugo Morales
touched on this also.
The changing - rapidly changing
demographics of the country
which will start to be
recognized even then.
The Hart-Celler Act, the
Immigration Act was rewritten
in 1965 and even though it would
take the rest - a generation,
it has reshaped America.
So in this time period
I'm talking
about from the 60's till now,
the Asia America community went
from 1% of the population
and now we're 6%,
we're over 20 million
and the fastest growing.
And Hugo mentioned
the statistics
for the Latino community.
S the premise that we all had
as this whole enterprise
was getting underway was
where would these voices
of other communities
for whom our presence in
media over all was an absence
or was one of stereotypes.
So for Asian Americans you know
in entertainment media we are
only you know the villains
in war movies or we're house
boys or we're gangsters
in China Town or laundry men.
And yet we have this inspiration
of the Civil Rights movement
to recognize how important
it was for us to be able
to participate in society.
So, the mechanism for us
in the minority consortium
and the wisdom of
the corporatino
for public broadcasting
was to help insure
that there was a
pipeline of programming by
and about these new
minority communities.
And we've been doing this
between 35 and 40 years all
of us, the five members
of the organization.
One of the things that I
- one of the first points
that I wanted to make
though and response now
to your question was that we
have learned something deeper
in this construct that it
was important ot include the
perspectives of people of
color in telling diverse kinds
of stories, be they about
history or social issues
or even our cultural history.
And I think at first we thought
we were presenting authentic
images that our own
communities could recognize.
So one piece that's really
important is you can't fully
participate in the
society unless
in some ways you see yourself
and your story is
told in the society.
The second poitn I think we came
to undersatnd relatively quickly
after that was that these
stories needed to be
for all Americans though and not
just for our own communities.
The Asian American community
would be a good example
because we're so diverse
and so different in language
and cultural backgrounds that
in some ways you're an expert
and know culture in a sense in
this construct of Asia America.
But I would say in the recent
years and this is where I want
to end my thoughts on
this, I think we now -
where we are today in
this quesiton of really
who is an American and what is
it that makes America great.
It's clear that I think in
some ways we tood for granted
that there was an acceptance.
That diversity was an
important and a key factor
of the American experience.
But it is vital that we
stand in for this notion
of what this country can
be and that we're not just
about our racial stories.
You know diversity is within
each of our communities as well.
And Ithink that's
th elarger piece
to reshift the way we all talk
about what is our
common history.
The way we examine things
and I think we're still
exploring what these different
points of view mean and it's
a journey we'll all need to be
on because we don't have the
guide stone of a you know,
sort of White European
male dominated
through line of history.
>> Pat Aufderheide:
Thank you very much.
Does anybody want to
jump in before I -
>> Clayborne Carson: I think
one of the points I'd make is
that all of us in some
ways are beneficiaries
of the technological changes
and that have lessoned the cost
and the - some would
say even the skill level
to get it to filmmaking.
So, that it has become much,
much easier to do what you know
like a film like Eyes
on the Prize today you
could probably do it
for much less money,
simply because the equipment
would b eso much less,
the editing euqipment,
all of that sort of thing.
And I think that looking
forward into the future,
what I see coming out of
African American filmmaking is
that proliferation is kind
of pulling us in you know,
even within the African
American community.
Now you have gay
filmmakers, black filmmakers
who might be trying to
describe that experience.
Ou have so many - so much
diversity within each
of these communities
that one thing I fear is
that it's very difficult
to get a sense in a -
right now for example
I've been involved in more
than two dozen documentary
films about black American life
and most of it 20th century.
And it seems like the pace
of that keeps increasing
and I think ther
eis that concern,
that we're losing a sense
of even the commonality
of being black, must
less being American.
And maybe that's good because
otherwise you would not have a
sense that these
communities exist.
But in terms of trying to get
a sense of it you know for many
of my students I teach - in fact
I'll be teaching next quarter a
course on Black independent
film.
And I find that maybe one
student might have seen some
of these fairly famous
films, Charles Burnett,
people who have really
made major contributions.
They haven't evne
seen early Spike Lee.
So it's - they might have
seen Malcolm X, but that's it.
So I thikn that one of the
problems wer're going to have is
that there are audiences
but it's going to be smaller
and smaller rather
than larger and larger.
>> Pat Aufderheide:
Let me actually address
the changing market place
for documentaries and I'd love
to have any of yoru responses.
This is a point at which Netflix
is busy giving people $450,000
to make [Inaudible]
and oops sorry,
and is launching entire lines.
You've got Vice and Vulture
doing instant video journalism.
You've got buzz feed explainers
apparently educating an entire
new generation.
And you've got cable channels
just stuffed with wall
to wall something that looks
sort of like maybe documentary.
And you have a legacy
that's been built up largely
through the hard work of
public television that is -
that honors the notion
of documentary
as like a really
authentic true thing.
At the same time you have an
enormous proliferation and in -
weeping into the
marketplace of Netflix,
Amazon and so many more.
So what's the role now of
public television documentary.
You know surely not
the only game in town.
Expensive, oh my God compared
to like almost any other kind -
source for documentary and
relatively slow compared to some
of the others, what's the role?
No pressure?
But if you could
provide us the answer -
>> David Fanning: It's
an enormous challenge.
I think one of the great
challenges is going
to be you know how do you
pick your way through all
of this stuff and know what's
true and what's trustworthy
and people maybe won't
care about that as much.
There's going to be an enormous
amount of material that's
out there in the
world being produced
in all these different areas.
And it's going to be
manipulated and used
because this is the most
manipulative of media.
And it's going to be - and so
we're going to have a harder
and harder time trying to
figure out what we can trust.
The trust brand and
the trust brand goes
to very expensive you know
high octane documentaries made
with big budgets for HBO, and
for Net Flix and others as well.
It's very easy to put your hand
on the scale in documentaries
and to be able to manipulate
this medium towards certain
points of view.
There is nothing easier
than to kind of you know,
Michael Moore's famous film of
Fahrenheit 911 in the sort of -
the use - getting
Wolfowicz and being able
to sorto get those
seequences, fish in a barrrel.
It's not hard to do,
it's very easy to be able
to manipulate archival material
and to use it in different ways,
to lay a voice over it.
So we have a deep worry I think
behind all of this as to where -
as to what lies behind it
and where do you have trust?
Anything that we can hold onto
is to say that we really believe
that you can trust us.
And the way in which you
trust us is the body of work
and the way in which we keep
doing it and also to make it
as transparent as possible.
So, we made - for me one of the
great err moments in the life
of [Inaudible] was 1995,
we just done a film
on Waco, the inside story.
And we'd done all these
interviews with major FBI guys
who were part of
negotiating with Koresh.
We even had the audio tapes
of the actual negotiations
and I kept saying "Can't
we put these audio tapes,
make a radio show"
and somebody said
"You can put it on the web".
What's that?
1995 we built a - we
built a website for Waco,
the Inside Story with
that archival material.
Plus I said, "Well can't we
put the whole film on there"
and they said, "You
can't do that yet".
And so thenwe put
the interviews up.
And all the interviews
for these were -
and that website exists today.
People still actually write to
us about that website from '95.
And then from then on once we
began publishing all of the -
edited longer versions
of the primary source
materials behind the front line,
so that last week,
second film that ran
of Putin's revenge there
were 65 interviews there,
a body of work that's both
historical important -
now that's not going ot persuade
the average person that's doing
it, that there is - that
they're going to go off and hunt
through the interview material -
>> Pat Aufderheide: You
made it transparent.
>> David Fanning: But you
made it completely transparent
but in some way that
seeps deep intothe culture
that we can keep doing this if
we raise the bar really high
and hold to that bar, then we
begin to hold onto who we are
and why we remain the
only place anywhere
in the media culture
that does that.
And so that's our -
>> Pat Aufderheide: Okay
so that's your answer.
Want to go Margaret?
>> Margaret Drain: Yeah
what I wanted to say is
that you can take that
trust too and we all had
to learn using new platforms.
And it was challenging in
many ways because we had been
so schooled in the delivery
of hour long documentaries
or in the case of American
Experience six hour long
documentaries or four
hour documentaries,
which were big biographies
of presidents.
So we had to learn how to
use the material on You Tube
and we had to learn
pod casting and we had
to learn all the different
platforms, mobile platforms
where we could deliver the
same kind of content,s horter
but the same - we hope
carries the same branding
and the same scrutiny that goes
into an hour long documentary
and deliver it to your
students who are not going
to be watching hour
long documentaries.
I mean unless somebody
leads them to it
and shows them what
the benefits are
and like the range
of interest is.
>> David Fanning: And they're
doing that, we're doing that.
We're getting millions of
viewers through Facebook.
>> Clayborne Carson: We're
sitting in an archive
that we I think for
anydocumentary one
of the most important
tasks is whatdo you do
with all the material that
you've brought together,
especially the video material.
And I think one of the most
important decisions for Eyes
on the Prize was to put it in
an archive where now you can go
and watch the entire
Coretta King interview
or any other interview
done during that time.
>> Pat Aufderheide: So Steve
we're going to run out of time.
I want to make sure that we
get your answer for the -
the answer for trust has
been partly transparency,
but it's also been partly brand,
you know because we are PBS,
we are American Experience,
we are Frontline.
And you're dealing with
a different community
who are independent filmmakers,
in your case specificall
Asian American filmmakers,
but each consortia does.
And in the series they showcase
their work, anthologize all
of this work which is
very, very differnet.
How do you address Clay's
point about centrifeal universe
of information out there?
>> Stephen Gong: You know
historically our stuff shows
up into the system
through a variety of ways,
not through one particular
strand, one brand.
Although in recent
times in fact,
we have a project that's going
on in American Experience next
May that makes extensive use
of archival materials and
we're also participating
in the archives of
public braodcasting,
I'm really proud of.
But to speak in general of this
you know, hundred titles a year
that colelctively come
from independent
sources, through ITVS.
We put our stuff on POV that
many of you may know about.
I - you know I am optimistic
moving into the future
because this is what we
all have to learn how
to incorporate many more points
of view and many more voices
in public broadcasting.
And if you stay true to that and
it's absolutely mission driven,
what we heard earlier.
It is the future.
And then make use of this
incredible education network.
I'm going to set up
the next panel for you.
PBS learning media, which we
you know put our materials on
and make available to teachers
that I feel very confident
about the future
of this enterprise
because there are
thousands, tens of thousands
of young makers who really
want to speak authentic stories
that don't necessarily have
to be in commercial media
and be all about selling a
product or titillating people
or even in the best sense
just to entertain alone.
I think ther eare so
many issues that we share
and public broadcasting,
if it stays true
to the mission is
that singular place.
>> Pat Aufderheide:
So we're going to -
we've got three more minutes and
I'd like to be able to use them
to talk to the issue you
addressed, which is archives.
And Clay has told us about -
is Eyes on the Prize
in PB somewhere?
>> Stephen Gong:
Yes, at St. Louis.
>> Pat Aufderheide:
Is [Inaudible],
do you want to explain
[Inaudible]?
>> Stephen Gong: There's
many wonderful things,
[Inaudible] is an online digital
archive of oral histories
by the Japanese American
community
and we have placed a
number of our collections,
the Lonnie Dane collection
when she interviewed hundreds
and hundreds of 442
veterans from World War II,
the Japanese Americans.
We've placed all those
interviews on that source.
But all of the other kinds
of works, they're going to go
into the Library of Congress
as part of our collections.
>> David Fanning: I would just
recommend seeing the Putin's
Revenge stuff.
It was done with Duke
and it's got the -
so state of the art
technology, 65 interviews,
they're all video interviews.
You can both read it and be able
to track the video
at the same time.
You can reach in and clip
a piece out and share it.
And it's the most
interactive profoundly sort
of impressive archive.
>> Pat Aufderheide:
Fantastic and in terms
of APB is there frontline
material -
>> David Fanning:
I think it's due.
Karen tells me it's in
the pipeline where -
we're on the way, the
body of work to come in.
>> Margaret Drain: I just
want to go back a little bit
to something Colson had said
about the appetite
for documentaries.
I also am on the board
of POV the independent
documentary series.
And I am astonished every
year we have an open call
and we get more than
1,000 entries
from independent producers.
And of those it has to be called
to like - we've got 18 slots.
So that's every single
year and even
after the -during the you
know, in the middle of the year
when there's no entry date
you get - they get inundated
with phone calls or they
tapes or they get you know,
links to films that
have been produced.
So there's something going on,
it reminds me of the time I was
at CBS and they announced
the death of the documentary.
I don't think we can say that
the documentary is dying.
I see quite the opposite.
I see this hunger in
young people made possible
by technology in some cases
and also just this kind
of incessant fervent curiosity
that they have about
their world.
And they're making these films
for practically nothing and some
of them are really terrific.
So I'm optimistic.
>> Clayborne Carson: Two
words that have not come up
and that are really central in
this are intellectual property.
And I think that in
general scholarship
and documentary filmmakers
have not been aggressive enough
in using fair use.
I think that in part, that
comes from when particular film
that I was involved in when
it came to being shown on PBS,
PBS required certain
kinds of coverage
for obvious reasons,
legal reasons.
And that forced them to
go back and in this case,
have to take out things.
I think at every level
intellectual property issues
have been crucial.
Not so much in terms of cost.
But just uncertainty about use.
>> Pat Aufderheide: And people
all being on the same page
about what they regard
as acceptable,
which is where the best
practices have been
somewhat helpful.
All right, last comments
because we have
like 15 seconds left, go.
>> Thank you.
>> Pat Aufderheide:
Okay your 15 seconds.
>> Margaret Drain: I thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Karen Cariani:
Thank you everybody.
Our next panel is
going to begin.
We're going to show some clips,
which I hope you'll stay
seated this time to watch.
It's on educational uses
of public broadcasting
and it will begin - the
panel will begin at 5:10,
but we're going to
start clips right now.
>> Our next panel on
the educational uses
of public broadcasting is
the person who during most
of my tenure as the head of
WGBH held the purse strings,
first at PBS and then at CPB
because she had the most
important programming jobs
in those two institutions.
Not simultaneously I would say.
Jennifer Lawson was the
executive vice president
of programming and
promotion services at PBS.
And then was senior vice
president for television
and digital content at CPB and
during a little bit of time
between those two she ran
the Howard University Public
Station, WHUT.
Jennifer has received
numerous awards and honors
for her work in public media.
The Hollywood Reporter
named her at one point one
of the 50 most influential women
in entertainment in the world;
so Jennifer take it away.
>> Jennifer Lawson: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much.
Education is a fundamental
element of public broadcasting.
Public television
was established
as educational television first
in many places around
the country.
The E in the call letters of
many stations like WETA or KCET
in Los Angeles or SCETV in South
Carolina references education.
And several of the 362 public
television stations are licensed
to universities such as the
one Henry just mentioned WHUT
at Howart University or
Arizona PBS, which originated
at Arizona State Univeristy.
Public television together
with public non-commercial
radio combined to serve
as the most consistent
and significant place
for information learning,
for listenrs
and viewers of all ages.
WE'll discuss public
broadcastings educational
underpinnings, its legacy
and how the preservation
of this content creates
future opportunities.
I have the privilege now
of introducing our
distinguished panel
and we have here Paula Apsell,
who is senior executive producer
of NOVA and director of
the WGBH science unit.
NOVA has won every major
broadcasting award,
including the Emmy,
the Peabody, the AAAS,
Codley Science Journalism Award
and the DuPont Columbia
Gold Baton,
as well as an Academy
Award nomination.
Paula has also been
personally recognized
with numerous individual awards
including the Carl Sagan Award
given by the Council of
Scientific Society Presidents.
NOVA is a favorite of
teachers who make extensive use
of its high quality educational
materials and its website
with popular short foreign
videos and though leader columns
as one of the most
popular on PBS.org.
Lloyd Morrisett.
Lloyd is a co-creator of
Sesame Street and a co-founder
of Sesame Workshop, formeraly
the Children's Television
Workshop which produces
Sesame Street.
He was board chair of
the workshop for 30 years
and is now a trustee
and chairman emeritus.
He is also an experimental
psychology scholar,
a former vice president of
the Carnegie corporation
and the Carnegie Foundation for
the advancement of teaching.
He was president of the John
and Mary R. Markle
Foundation from 1969 to 1998.
He is currently a trustee of
public agenda, a non-partisan,
non-profit organization
conducting research
to inform public policy issues.
Kathryn Ostrofsky teaches
in the department of history
at Angelo State Universitiy
in San Angelo, Texas.
Kathryn's areas of research
and teaching include 20th
century US cultural history,
sound studies, television
studies, the history of race
and ethnicity, and the history
of media and communications.
She is also working to
preserve audio visual
and paper arvhical
sources related
to children's television.
She has a doctorate in
history from the University
of Pennsylvania and her
oral history of the 1970's
through the sounds of
Sesame Street has led
to numerous speaking engagements
and conference presentations.
She is under contract with the
University of California Pres
for a book on this topic.
I'd like to start with Lloyd
Morrisett and to talk a bit
about the origins
of Sesame Street.
And I know that you were
at the Carnegie Foundation
and had a very good overview
of the state of education
in America at that time.
And I would just - I think
it would be really useful
if you would put Sesame Street
in the context of those times
and tell us a little bit about
what led to its creation.
>> Lloyd Morrisett:
Well for those of you
who are expecting
Elmo, I'm not Elmo.
I think to talk about
the origins
of Sesame Street
you have to recreat
in your minds the
events of that decade.
And I'm going to list them here
and I'm going to read the list
because I don't want
to leave anything out.
1960, television may have given
Senator John F. Kennedy the edge
he needed to defeat
Vice President Nixon
in the first televised
presidential debate.
Kennedy wins the election
by a margin of 113,000 votes
out of 69 million votes cast.
1961, FCC chairman Newton
Minow makes his famous speech
declaring that television
is a vast wasteland.
1962, 90% of Americans
own a television set,
ABC begins broadcasting
in color.
The Federal government
funds first funds -
the Federal Government
funds public broadcasting
through the education
television facilities act.
June of 1962, President Kennedy
federalizes Alabama's national
guard and orders
Governor George Wallace
to allow two black students to
be enrolled at the university.
Just recounting these events
I find them very emotional.
In January of 1962 Martin
Luther King delivers his
"I have a Dream" speech.
In August more than 200,000
Americans march on Washington
in support of Civil Rights.
1964 the 24th Amendment
to the Constitution makes US
Poll taxes unconstitutional.
March 1964 President Johnson
declares the war on poverty.
He signs an Economic
Opportunity Act in August
and appoints R. Sargent
Shriver to head the new Office
of Economic Opportunity.
Again in 1964 President
Johnson signs the bill
enacting Medicare.
The Great Society is underway.
In August of 1964 Congress
approves the Tonkin Gulf
Resolution authorizing
Presidnet Johnson
to take all necessary measures
to repel any armed attack
against forces of
the United States
and to prevent further
aggression.
December of 1964 President
Johnson announes a substantial
increase in USA to South Vietnam
to restrain mounting
infiltration of men
and equipment by
the Hanoi Regime
in support of the Vietcong.
In 1965 January in the State
of the Union message President
Johnson outlines program
for the Great society that will
eliminate poverty in America.
In February Dr. Martin
Luther King is arrested
in Soma, Alabama.
In February also Malcolm
X is assassinated.
Coincidentally during
National Brotherhood week.
June of 1965 Congress
authorizes the use
of ground troops in Vietnam.
A complete ground
offensive is underway
and the Vietcong will collapse
in a few weeks said President
Johnson's national security
advisor, Walt Russell,
not months but weeks.
125,000 troops are in Vietnam.
In August of that year the
Voting Rights Act becomes law.
And in August of that year
the Carnegie Commission
on educational television begins
its landmark study of broadcast.
In 1967 public broadcasting
laboratory airs
over national educational
television.
It is a Sunday night
magazine program designed
to showcase the relevance and
importance of public television.
We'll come back to that because
that was a much more important
historically in public
broadcasting then is
generally recognized.
In March of 1968
President Johnson announces
that he will not accept the
nomination for another term.
His presidency has become
another casualty of Vietnam War.
Ini 1968 in April Martin
Luther King is assassinated.
In 1969 regular national public
broadcasting television program
begins five nights a week.
In November of that year
Sesame Street goes on the air.
Now as you can tell from
my emotions this was a very
turbulent time.
It strongly affected all of us,
all of us who were alive then.
And it was out of that in part,
that Sesame Street was born.
We started working
on the idea in 1966.
And the people that came
to us to help Dave Connell
for example our executive
vice president,
Joan Cooney obviously joined
me and the original idea.
All of us were very affected
by the events I've discussed.
And so Sesame Street was in
part, born out of a belief
in Civil Rights that we all had.
The fact that it appeared
on public television was
somewhat of an accident.
When we first started
to raise money for it
in 1966 Doc Howe had become
commissioner of Education
and he had been formerly
president, superintendent
of schools in Scarsdale.
And he was one of the first
people we talked to about it.
He - after some deliberation
overruled his staff and said
that he would find
4 million dollars
to help us get on the air.
So, with that 4 million
dollars plus the million dollars
that Carnegie had already put
up we had 5 million dollars.
Lou Housman was Doc Howe's
point person in liasoning
between the Office of
Education and what was going
to become Sesame Workshop.
Lou came out of NBC television
and he strongly believed
that the program should be
on commercial television.
He said "Where are
the people going,
they're on commercial
television.
That's where you have to be".
So, we took that advice
seriously and I met with NBC,
CBS, Lou W Broadcasting
and got very nice -
a very nice reception
but no money.
No air time.
The program was fully funded
but we couldn't understand,
I couldn't understand
in my naivette why
with a fully funded program
we couldn't have any air time.
Later I realized and
I've realized it ever
since that the advertising
part weren't interested
in having those minutes
sold that way.
They wanted to raise money
around the program
and they couldn't.
So the commercial broadcasters
turned us down and just
at that point the public
broadcasting act had been signed
and public broadcasting
needed programming.
We needed air time, it was a - I
won't say it was made in Heaven,
but it was certainly made
by an accident of history.
So, the - the things that
made it possible in addition
to the ones that
I've already cited,
are that the people essentially
who created the climate
to accept the idea
of a children's television
program were all in their place.
John Gardener had been my boss
at Carnegie, was a good friend.
Doc Howe had also
become a friend.
Other people who were
not directly involved
in the origins, but created
the climate in Washington
that made it possible.
Newton Minow was one, he's
been a friend the rest
of his life for me.
Henry Gellar who some of you
may remember, was an ardent fan
of the publics use
of broadcasting
and not giving it away free
to commercial broadcasters.
The other person I'd mention,
whose name has already
come up is Doug Cater.
Doug Cater was Lyndon Johnson's
special assistant for education.
He shepherded the
Public Broadcasting Act
through the process of
getting it to Congress
and he was also a great
friend of the kidns of htings
that we were trying to do.
Joan Cooney had been at NBC and
then she had been at channel 13
where she was a commercial
- not a commercial,
a documentary producer and
had three good documentaries
to her name.
So, essentially not only
had the climate of opinion
in the country been fertilized
I'll say by the events
of the 1960's, but the
particular people I've mentioend
were all interested
in the public's use
of public facilities
and public education.
They are what made the
idea become possible.
I think I'll stop
there Jennifer.
>> Jennifer Lawson: Terrific.
Terrific now thank you.
[ Applause ]
Paula. Your work exemplifies
informal educaiton.
You've helped popularize
and demystify science
and science educaiton
and you've given exposure
to some scientists that has made
them as popular as rock stars,
Neil deGrasse Tyson,
Brian Greene,
I mean you know it's easy
to go places and people go
"Oh wow Brian Greene,
string theory".
And so it's - and then you've
also shown us women and people
of color in the sciences
routinely throughout
your series.
With NOVA what's the origin, how
do we get from there to here?
>> Paula Apsell: That's good.
I first of all just want to say
I'm just awed to be setting next
to Lloyd because my daughter
Natalie is here with me today
and I just can see in my mind's
eye, this makes me emotional.
And she and her sisters
little girls woud be sitting
on that couch every
single day at 4:00,
their thumbs in their mouth.
A bomb could have
gone off in that room
and they would not have moved.
And what they learned
from Sesame Street way beyond
the importance of the letters,
the lessons about life,
about ethics, about morality,
about how you treat other
people of all different kinds,
even if they're not
familiar to you,
and now as everyone
knows I have a grandson.
And he watches the science
kid and also Sesame Street
and the other programs on PBS.
So, as well as being a content
generator, I'm a recipient
of all the good things that PBS
does for kids and educationally,
and it's just - really
it's just overwhelming.
I feel so fortunate
to be a part of this.
Now on to NOVA.
So, education is in NOVA's DNA.
We've been producing content
for teachers and students
for as long as we've been
on PBS, and that's 44 years
which is an eternity
in television.
And now I have to
mention another man
that I think is a
really great person
and that is Michael
Lambersino who started NOVA.
Michael just had -
[ Applause ]
Michael just had a really
good idea, very simple.
His idea was sciecne is
not a collection of facts,
it's a story and if you tell
the story with characters
and with visuals then
people will watch
and they will learn,
but they will enjoy.
And it will change their
opinion about science and make -
help them to undersatnd what
an important part of our lives
and what an important, I
would say cultural institution
that it is really a thrill
to get a better understanding
of our world.
And Michael always knew that
it was very important for NOVA
to go to teachers as well,
and they should have
supplementary materials
that would help them use
NOVA in the classroom.
So for years and years and
years we made teachers plans,
which had all sorts of
suggestions and tips
and activities for
the classroom.
But teaching changes, education
changes and technology changes.
And nowit began as teachers
domain at WGBH went to PBS
as PBS learning media.
A fabulous digital
library, the central hub
for all the educational content
produced by all the PBS brands
and it now reaches more
than 2 million educators,
which is amazing.
And WGBH is the stem
lead for PBS LM
and NOVA itself has contributed
more then 900 resources,
mainly video clips,
lots of animation
and these are all contextualized
with teaching standards
and discussion questions
and background essays
and we promote these
clips really rigorously
to teachers at conferences.
We also create new digital
content like NOVA labs,
which is a platform of
science games and interactives
that uses real scientific data.
And these are actually, they
were originally designed
for teens to use at home and
not as an in school activity,
but they turned out to be
really popular with teachers,
which use them all the time
and actually assign them
to their students
to do as homework.
So to date, that platform
has engaged nearly more
than 4 million unique viewers.
And our education lab, and
I just find this amazing,
is NOVA's most visited page,
so I find that amazing.
We have an upcoming two
hour program on black holes,
which is hosted by
astrophysicist Janna Levin
and to go with that we create
an iPad app that invites players
to navigate the cosmos
by hurling stars
at various celestial objects.
Kind of like Angry Birds
but it's for the universe.
But that's - that's our what we
call our educational content,
whether it's informal or formal
but science is for everyone.
And so is NOVA, and so of course
I love it when people tell me
"I went into science
or engineering
as a result of watching NOVA".
But really we want to stoke
curiosity and excitement
about science in
people of all ages.
So we have a very
rich historic archive
that chronicles scientific
research over four decades.
If you want ot know the
origins of genetic engineering
or how artificial intelligence
got started you know you can
really - we've been covering
that throughout the 20th century
and now 21st century on NOVA
and at any given time we have
about 100 full length
programs available to everyone
to watch online on
PBS.org for free.
And we also reach out
into the community.
We've created a coalition of
science caf's more than 400
of them and we ourselves,
every month at WGBH studio,
at the Boston Public Library,
we hold a science caf
for anyone who wants to come.
And these science
caf's are usually held
at non-traditional settings.
They're a chance for
people to actually interact
with real scientists and
it's really kind of amazing
to know how many people in their
daily life don't get a chance
to really meet a
scientist and talk to them.
And I think that's why
people get very wrong ideas
about sicentisits
and about science.
And so - and people
really enjoy these settings
when they're held.
And an example of this is
we also of our reaching
out into the community is our
program school of the future,
which actually looked at the
issue of educational equity
and what kinds of new techniques
and technologies can be used
to help equalize things.
We organzed 293 communtiy
screenings at K12 settings,
at community organizations
and really all over the place.
And people came and they really
engaged in the discussion
of how education can be
made better for everyone.
And finally and this
really touches the point
that you made Jennier, we want
people from all backgrounds
to appreciate the importance
of science in our lives
and the crucial role
that science literacy
plays in a democracy.
And now CPB with their
help, we've been able
to develop short form video that
explains the science behind many
of the stories that are
dominating the news cycle.
If you - embedded on all
of our work is the mmandate
that we have on public media
to reflect the diversity
of all people and
experiences in our country.
We are 100% committed to
increasing diversitiy in front
of and behind the camera
by actively cultivating
both producers
and scientists of color.
And I really invite you to
take a look at any current NOVA
and you'll be able ot
see what we're doing.
But equally important to that,
we're actually expanding the
scope of the stories we tell,
focusing more on the ways that
science impacts social jsutice.
Our episode last spring
Poison Water, about the Flint,
Michigan water crisis
is an exmaple of that
with all its associated
digital educational content.
I also believe that this really
illustrated the importance
of education being embedded in
a production unit like NOVA.
Our education director Ralph
Bukay who taught biology
in an inner city high school in
Philadephia and can really share
that experience with all of us.
He has a leadership
role in our unit
and not only does this
integration drive many
of our initiatives,
but the lessons
that we learn educational and
digital and broadcast go back
and forth and they are all
enriched by this integration
and that helps us better to
serve the American people.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jennier Lawson: Kathryn
you've studied children's
television and Sesame
Street in real depth.
And you've learned a lot
about the role of the series
in educating pre-schoolers
but through your work
and through the particular
angles
that you have approached Sesame
Street you've learned a lot
about our society as well.
And could you share some of
your observations with us?
>> Kathryn Ostrofsky:
Yeah I think I'm here
to represent the generation
that did grow up on PBS
and my education of course
started with Sesame Street
and is continuing
with Sesame Street
through my graduate school
and now in my teaching.
I just never stopped
watching it.
So I've been asked to talk about
public broadcasting as history,
and that's why I use Sesame
Street as a historical source.
But so much of public
broadcasting of course,
can be used as historical
sources.
And the way that we
often think about that is
that public broadcasting
recorded our past,
the public affairs
shows, the talk shows,
recordings of great
performances are now an archive
of our history.
And that is true,
but as a scholar
and as a teacher I am
more intersted in thinking
about the ways that public
broadcasting is our history
because it is a forum,
it is a vehicle,
a tool for which we seek
to understand our past
and our present and
shape our future.
I think this is a tehme that's
been running throughout all the
panel this afternoon, the theme
of democratization
and interactivity.
So this happens from both
angles, from the producers
as well from the audiences.
From the producers, the way that
they approach their programs
and Laird just doesn't report
the news, he analyzes it.
Dick Cavett doesn't just
ask boilerplate questions
of celebrities, he engages
them in a conversation
that can take any turn.
Even almost coming
to physical blows.
Lloyd Morrisett and Jim Gance
Cooney did not just television
to teach letters and numbers,
they designed a program
that reflected the
cultural sensibilities
of the urban minority children
that they hoped to serve.
And they built the program
to be able to evolve
and to be responsive
to society's changing
educational needs
and cultural needs.
So, all of these progrms are
- they're not just series
of short conversations
or presentations,
rather they are decades long
conversations between producers
and audiences about
issues that matter to us.
So public broadcasting
creates in particualr,
creates a really rich
record of these discussions
of these long conversations
because it's funding comes
from the government
and philanthropic foundations
and viewers like you.
They producers and stations
constantly have to articulate
to their audiences and to their
funders what they're doing,
why they're doing it like that
and what impact it's having.
It creates a paper trail that
is amazing for historians.
Because public broadcasting
is for the people
and it's mobilizing this
technology not for advertisers
but for the audiences
themselves, the audiences,
educators, social activities
have through the years felt
that they could and should
make their voices heard
in public media as a
collaborative effort
to improve programs or to use
public broadcasting as a tool
for broader social change.
So they do talk back
to their televisions
as Nicholas Johnson suggested.
So in the case of Sesame Street
for instance, the producers
and the audiences agreed that
the show should provide models
for ideal community
interactions.
But as Lloyd was just talking
about there's a lot going
on in the 60's and 70's.
There's Civil Rights, cultural
pride movements proliferating
and fragmenting in the 1970's.
So, all of these people who
are invested in Sesame Street
in some way don't agree on what
that ideal community should look
like or sound like, how
those people should behave.
So, cast members,
staff, parents, critics,
advocacy groups like the
National Organization of Women
and the UCLA Chicano Studies
Center had ongoing discussions
about characters - how
characters should speak,
what musical guests to
feature, how to represent
and celebrate diversity without
perpetuating stereotypes.
And there was no easy answers
and luckily Sesame Street is a
variety show so they could sort
of experiment with
all these things
at the same time
and see what worked.
So - but this engagement with
social issues also happens long
after the programs first air.
And it's - it has
become clich to say
that documetnaries bringthe past
to life, but they certainly do
in my classroom, not
just metaphorically
but these programs
often have the power
to continue the traditions
that they discuss.
The first episode
of Eyes on the Prize
for example is called Awakenings
and it shows how media coverage
of the lynchings, lynching of
Emmett Till and the sham trial
that allowed his murderers to
go free led to a published -
public consciousness about
the conditions of Jim Crowe
and inspired Civil
Rights actions.
Watching the documentary itself
is a consciousness raising
experience for my students
and there is no more
powerful demonstration for why
so many people risked their
lives for Civil Rights.
One episode of the
American Experience series
on Latino Americans
covers the 1968 walk outs
through which Chicano high
school students took control
of their education and sought
to understand their place -
the place of themselves
and their families
in American history
and American society.
And for one of my
students a couple
of years ago she had heard about
the walk outs from her mother
who had participated in them,
but to see those events depicted
on national television, in a
US history survey class did the
same thing for her, it inspired
her to take her own education
into her own hands and figure
out her place in society.
So, public television, we're
here talking about preservation.
Public television and radio
need to be preserved not just
because they have recorded
history, because they continue
to be the material that
we use every day to engage
with our past or our
future, shape our future.
[ Applause ]
>> Jennifer Lawson: I think your
comments underscore what has
been said too at some
of the other panels
about the incredible
importance of the material,
not just during the time
that it is broadcast
but it's archival
value into the future.
Before we come back
to preservation,
I'd like to go back to Lloyd for
a quick question that relates
to your background
in psychology too,
and that is that for example a
national study recently revealed
that 50% of American
children under the age
of 18 have experienced
a traumatic event
such as witnessing violent acts
or experiencing natural
disasters.
Last month Sesame Street, Sesame
Workshop launched an initiatve
to help children cope with
these traumatic experiences.
And Sesame Street puppets have
often in the past been used
to help children talk
about events like a death
in a family or divorce.
And when you and Joan
were starting Sesame,
did you envision this kind of
therapeutic role for the series
in its early days, or is
that something that evolved?
>> Lloyd Morrisett: It evolved.
The early days question
we were tasked
with answering can
television teach anything?
We had to answer
that with a positive
in order to gain more funding.
That was the hard work of it.
So initially we concentrated
on things that were taught
in school, needed to be
taught in school, letters
and numbers and so on.
And could be easily measured;
those were the things
that we were really
trying to look out.
And fortunately the study
that came out showed
that people watched
more learned more.
With that start and with the
confidence that we were going
to be able to continue once we
got a second season funding,
we then began to broaden
the curriculum to take
into account some of the things
that you're talking about.
Although the real change
probably came much later.
The military families project
was probably the most imoprtant
change in that regard.
And now of course as you
mentioned traumatic events,
abuse, autism would
be another example
where we would not have been
able to do that initially,
but as the program evolved we
have been able to do more of it.
>> Paula Apsell:
I'd like to address
that issue can public
television teach anything;
I think it's really an important
question and very important
for NOVA in a way
because part of our -
we're always discussing was
we were you know 40 years ago
and we're still discussing
it is our primary function
to educate and to entertain.
We're always kind of talking
about how you blend
those two things.
But when you think back to
your own sceicne classes
and how the teacher was
always talking aobut things
that you couldn't understand
what he or she was talking
about because you
couldn't visualize it.
You had absolutely no
frame of reference for it.
And I think this one of the huge
values to PBS learning media
and to their whole -
their huge stem collectin
because it helps -
it provides visuals.
So when you're talking about
a volcano and what's going
on in the molten magma
under the earth -
I mean who really knows what
that means when you're a kid
and you've never
lived near a volcano
and you've never seen one.
But here you can
have an animation
and it can be contextualized
by your teacher
because there are -
the archive helps.
So I really I just hink
in terms of science,
visuals are just so important.
They also help both kids
and everyone take the world
from another perspective.
The design to show you things
that you can't see for yourself
and that in a way,
expands your world.
And that to me, is just
really one of the benefits
of the educational uses of
our material and of the fact
that we are fortunate enough to
be able to produce these things
and have the resources to do
so even though it's always a
struggle in the first place.
>> Jennifer Lawson: And you've
had in many cases the nature
of your funding on places like
the National Science Foundation
or the funding that
you've received
for Sesame Workshop has received
is required rigorous evaluation,
right?
And testing as a
part of the proving
that it has this
educational benefit.
>> Paula Apsell: Oh
rigorous evaluation.
But it's not - now one thing
that the National Science
Foundation and actually a lot
of other funders are going
off to is they want you
to use your material
not just to evaluate it,
to see if it's any good but
they want it to add to the body
of learning of how people learn
from the visual media
whether they get more
out of an hour long documentary,
out of short form video,
what the difference is,
what the difference is in their
attitudes towards science.
So we're really accumulating
with some of our projects
and we're workign with academics
on this because we're not -
I mean I'm a TV producers,
I couldn't begin to figure
out how to do these projects.
But to use them to really
understand the fundamentals
of science learning.
And it's very gratifying
that our material
can be used for that.
>> Jennifer Lawson: Now
Kathryn you had mentioned
to me a little earlier
that in addition
to the audio/visual materials
being so incredibly important
that there are other
resources like the kind
that Paula just mentioned or
the notes from the creation
of a program that
producers might just think
as real throw away.
That some of that has archival
value for scholars like you?
>> Kathryn Ostrofsky: Yes.
I've been using the Sesame
Street's research notes too.
I'm struck by the
parallels between the studies
and the outreach that NOVA
and Sesame Street have had.
They're also a paper
trail for learning
about how we learn from media.
Learning about what the history
of the discipline of psychology
or education or whoever
is doing these studies is.
And they're also
fun for me to look
at from a humanities
perspective,
because you do have certain
things that you're testing
for your show, but that's
doesn't mean that's all we can
learn from that data;
so I go in and read it
from a historians point of view
and find completely
differnet information
about for instance
cultural differences
between the Spanish speaking
and English speaking kids
about how they're
responding to music,
which is not what
was being tested.
It was how there was
learning the Spanish language.
But there's more
information there then is used
in your studies, so your studies
have broader impact beyond what
you're doing with them.
>> Jennifer Lawson:
And as we talk
about these preserving content
and materials from public media
and these documents, I
just also want to mention
that we problably haven't
represented fully enough the
broadest range of public media
because there's also
culture and the arts.
And that there is
so much I think,
in terms of performac
program, cultural programs
that are created
by producers both
at the national and local level.
And so I also want to bring
that into the discussion as well
as public media creating
a really,
really robust archive
of local content.
Most public media stations
and public radio really
do an incredible amount
at the local level and so
there's a wealth of material
and a history of commmunity
that's being created there
as well.
Now we have talked about
reaching the youngest viewers
and we've also talked
about adults in many ways,
although I must stay that
you're going far beyond adults
when I look at slimy,
gross science programs
that NOVA is a part of.
Gross science or some
of your other programs
that are what makes you
vomit is a - so I can -
>> Paula Apsell: I
mean it's your body,
you've got to undersatnd it.
>> Jennier Lawson: So I can
imagine you attracting a much
broader age range
but that has been one
of the challenges I think
tha thas plagued public media
for a number of years.
And I want to start with you
Lloyd and just going back
to the question did
Sesame Workshop
as a children's television
workshop, what efforts were made
in the sort of earlier years in
trying to go beyond preschoolers
and to reach the
pre-teens and teenagers?
>> Lloyd Morrisett: Well
as Paula has mentione din
producing a television show you
have to atract the audience as
well as teach them something.
And so Sesame Street was
designed in the beginning -
I need to start that again.
The viewing conditions in 1969
are extremely different then
they are today.
In 1969 typically families
had one television set,
the family watched together
and the parents could act
as an intermediary between
what was on the television set
and what the child learned.
You say, "Johnny
did you see that A"?
or "Johnny take a look
at what's coming up next,
it's going to be like" and
that gets Johnny's attention
to something on the set that
you want to teach about.
Now I think at the - I saw
that maybe 90% of adolescents
and above have smart phones.
Television sets are numerous and
often the child at whatever age,
two or three even controls
the set himself or herself.
So the problem of
maintaining an audience
and know what audience
you're really trying
to reach is much harder.
I don't think we've
figured it out yet.
But we certianly had the
idea from the beginning
that the adults had to be
atracted to the program
as well as the children.
>> Paul Apsell: I used to like
- 4:00 I was pretty tired.
I'd sit there and we'd
watch Sesame Street.
It appealed to adults as well.
I mean I felt like
there were two levels
that it was operating on.
>> Lloyd Morrisett: Laugh in,
which some of you may remember
was a very important precursor
to what we did.
We used a lot of the Laugh In
techniques in the early shows.
>> Jennifer Lawson: I think
it very definitely did.
The one piece that I remember
is I think it was Patti Labelle
singing "I love my X, I
miss my X" and there's
of course the letter
X on the screen.
But the look in her eyes
suggested otherwise.
So it definitely seemed as if
it was very consciously designed
to -
>> Lloyd Morrisett: It
was, no question of that.
The writers particularly
enjoyed doing that.
They liked to write one liners
and kids didn't get
it, but the adults did.
>> Paula Apsell: In
terms of the ages,
yes but I mean we all
worry in public media
about an aging audience.
I mean it's like
discussed constantly
and we're sweating constantly.
We try to really figure it
out how we can appeal
to younger people.
One thing we find is that
we have a very different
audience online.
That the audience
online is much younger.
And so the idea is that the
uadience online we do know
that they love to watch our
shows on their computer.
They love short form video, I
guess that's the whole thing
about the attention
span, I don't know.
But they also like to
watch our short form videos
and if we take them off, oh
our lawyers are right there.
But I have to say in two
minutes they're pirated and put
on You Tube and you take them
down and they go back up.
It's like a pop up,
whack a mole.
It is really amazing,
so they really -
I think this is a key to us.
Young people we know
do not have televisions
and watch television that much.
They watch on their phone,
they watch on their computer.
The hope is that they
will, youngsters do grow up
and very often they have
families and their life changes
and it starts to - and they
start to realize the value
of public media and they start
to join their local station.
And I think that there is,
maybe I'm just an optimist.
But I think if we can
keep reaching out to them
and hold them close to us
by various different
forms ofwhat we do,
we will migrate them in
a direction that many
of them will be watching
our programs.
Maybe that's just optimistic.
>> Kathryn Ostrofsky: I think
there's an uptapped potential
for that middle audience
between childrens and adults.
Certainly my students,
they're adults but they -
one of the things that I try
to do with the documetnaries
that I show in class is to
not just show a documentary
but do something with it.
And there are a few
documentaries
that tell us something about
the historical profession.
My freshman are watching
A Midwive's Tale
because I'm not in class today.
And my seniors are
wathicng American
Experience Documentaries.
But I - I - you can use
these documentaries to teach
about narrative structure,
since they use narrative
structure we just ehard.
You can teach them
about media literacy,
which I think is
really important skill
that they are not coming
to college with these days,
and we need it more than ever.
So there are creative ways
to use these programs beyond
simply the formal education
or informal education that
they were designed for.
>> Lloyd Morrisett: Jennifer you
haven't said anything about it
but the title Presrving
Public Media has two meanings.
It means archivally and it
also means continuing it.
And we do not now have
Newt Minow at the FCC.
We don't have John Gardener
at HEW and I would think
that there should be a
considerable amount of concern
about the enduring health
under the current
auspices of public media.
>> Jennier Lawson: I thought
that it was really quite
heartening to hear with some
of the earlier panels
who addressed that.
I thought it was really quite
heartening to hear their level
of optimism about public
broadcasting and it's future
and it's potential in that way.
But I welcome your
thoughts about this.
>> Paula Apsell: I was
going to say one thing is
that I think we just talked
a minute or so about age.
I mean the hope is that the
American public will demand the
preservaiton of public media.
You know we have to
have our fans out there.
They are our biggest asset,
and I think many of you
in this room remember under
few years ago, decades ago,
I don't remember when
it was in the 90's
when public media was
really threatened.
And people wrote letters,
millions of letters
and said no absolutely not, you
cannot take this away from us.
That is our prservation,
that is our guarantee.
So the concern I have is
yes indeed we want to expand
and get younger people.
Listen I love my older
viewers, keep watching.
Oldies but goodies, I love
you okay, don't stop waching.
People are living
longer and longer.
So it's great.
We do want to get younger
people but we also want to get,
I know this is near
and dear to your heart.
We want to get more diversity.
Not just because we're ethical
people, but also becauase
that is our survival, the
American demographic is changing
and we have to change with it.
And my job is to really find
ways to - and choose topics
that show people sceince
belongs to you, not just to me.
Listen sicence has been
white, we all know that.
It's changing it's bringing
many more minoritis into it.
We used to tear our
hair out to try
and find minority scientists
to put on the screen.
Now it's really - you know in
some fields it's chalelnging
but in many it's really not
hard at all That's great.
So one way is to really make
sure that we have scentists
of all different colors and
all different backgrounds
on the screen.
Another way is in the choice
of topics that we have
to choose topics that take
into account people's concerns.
And so hopefully this is not
something that's going ot
be accomplished.
We're not going ot expand our
percentage of minorities from 9
or 10% to 25% over night.
But my hope is that if we do
it right, we tell good stories
and we'r emuch more inclusive
in topic choice and people
that people will
respond by watching.
And you know when we took our
show poison water to Flint,
and we showed it in Flint.
And that ocmmunity, you
know we just - it was -
the reaction was just so amazing
this group of people who were -
these people were
citizen scientists.
They did not wait and
rely on scientists to come
in and do it for them.
They figured out more than
the scientists in a lot
of the agencies what was
going wrong with their pipes.
And then to see themselves
reflected
in a documentary how
they had taken a role
in their own survival
and the survival
of their children I think
they were really amazed
and I think it gave
them a different feeling
about public media.
That it became theirs and
you know it's not easy.
They're not zillions of topics
that you can do it with,
but I think it's imperative.
>> Jennifer Lawson:
I want to come back
to Lloyd's really
appropriate question
about preserving public
media for the future.
And but before I do that, I want
to just also get your thoughts
and we have just a quick minute.
I want to get your thoughts
about beyond the screen.
Because we've talked
about public broadcasting
and we're talking about
broadcasting and I know that all
of you are aware of public
media and you do your work
on so many other
platforms as well.
And I just would welcome your
speaking about the importance
of public media on those
additional platforms.
I think that you've
spoken to that you know
in a very articulate way Paula
about what NOVA has been doing.
But other thoughts
about beyond broadcast?
>> Lloyd Morrisett: We now
get an enormous number of hits
on You Tube where we've
provided a lot of clips
so that's the reuse of something
that's been done before
but is a very useful one.
>> Kathryn Ostrofsky: Thoughtful
curation of the things
that are available really
helps the professors who are
at most colleges and
univresities that have a lot
of students and not a lot
of time to prepare outside
of their fields in teaching;
so I would say it's
extremely important.
>> Jennifer Lawson: So the
thoughtful curation comes
into places like witih
PBS learning media.
I assume where then there's
already the thought given
to what age group, what
level, what the topic is,
all of these - nicely
tagged and everything.
>> Kathryn Ostrofsky: Yes
tagged, properly tagged
and if there are any interactive
things that can go along with -
there used to be an interactive
game of pretending you were
in the gold rush and
taking on a character
and seeing if you survived.
And it took about two minutes
to play and it went along
with the documentary
for the gold rush.
I can't find it anymore.
I hope it's there.
It may have moved or it
may have just been old,
and that's of course a problem.
>> Paula Apsell: You have to
ask the 10 year olds to find it
for you, they won't
have any problem at all.
>> Jennifer Lawson: So as a
final question just to come back
to this all important point
of - of we're at the end
of this wonderful day and all
of these really very,
very rich panels.
What about presrving
public media for the future?
>> Lloyd Morrisett:
I would worry most
about just not having
the budget go up.
Costs are going up
for everything else
and there are a lot of things
that budget can be used for
and we just keep it the same.
So in my view the strategy
is slow starvation.
>> Paula Apsell: I
don't want to starve.
As I always say, I'm
on the spending side
and I like that side.
But here is what I worry about,
and you just mentioned something
I thinkis very important,
which is the non
broadcast aspect of series
like the ones that we do.
And I know my documentary
friends
from the previous panel
were really aprpeciate news
and all of ours.
When we started our website
in 1996 we just figured okay,
we'll just take the same
stuff and we'll put it online
and maybe we'll you
know, put a few you know,
it felt like it was just going
to be a free edition to NOVA.
Now it's own mouth to
feed and it's getting
to be a gigantic mouth.
And sothe quesiton is and it's
so important because it is a way
to attract so many people
who are not going ot turn
on the television set.
And I think we certainly find
it's much harder to raise money
for digital then it is to
raise money for broadcast.
So I think that's something
we really have to figure out
and figure out with
the foundations
and the other funders that
have supported public media
in the past.
Because this is the
new world, this is it.
>> Kathryn Ostrofsky: Oftentimes
academics and broadcasters
and archivists live
in different worlds,
so I think we need more
events like this to bring all
of us together and that's
the first step conversations
like the ones we've had today.
>> Jennifer Lawson: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> We have one more
element to this panel.
We're going to let Newt
Minow have the last word,
but before we do, first of
all my thanks to all of you
and to you Jennifer for
the work on this panel.
I hope you have found this
afternoon as fascinating
as I have, being with these
founders of public media
and creators of some
of the most iconic
and imoprtant content
in public media.
And I'd be remis if I didn't
take us back at the very end
to the other meaning of the
word preserve and to talk just -
say a few words abou
the American archive
of public broadcasting.
Although I can't be quite as
articulate as Kathryn was.
I think, but we - this is
really the archive of our times.
Not just our national
times as you've heard
as Jennifer alluded
to, but alsothe times
of our communities,
geographically
around the country
from coast to coast.
And culturally and believe me
local commercial broadcasters
have not been able to
preserve their archives.
It's - it has been too expensive
for them, you know they had
to reuse those tapes or couldn't
spend the staff time given news
cycles and especially
now given news cycles,
endless news cycles.
So commercial broadcasters
really have not,
with a few exceptions been able
to preserve their archives.
It just wasn't their
business plan.
So it's more important
than ever that commercial -
that public media
preserve its archives
and it's also a very critical
part of our mission that we make
that archive accessible.
It's been part of the core
mission of public media
from the very beginning that
we make our work available
to everyone, no matter
where they are,
no matter what their means
are, their ability to pay
and especially in
this universe now
where almost everything
is behind a paywall
in media elsewhere.
So I'm very proud of the
progress we've been makign
through the American Archive
of Public Broadcasting
to put tehse works up online
and make them accessible.
I want to - as we close make
a special thank oyu again
to the two co-heads of
the American Archive
of Public Broadcasting,
Alan Gevinson in the back,
his hand is up there for
the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
And Karen Cariani from
WGBH right in front.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.